This is Jocko podcast number 119 with Echo Charles and me Jocko Willink good evening Echo good evening
On September 11th
400 miles from the collapsed World Trade Center towers
Three dozen passengers and crew aboard United flight 93 he remained in airborne purgatory
Starting at 9:30 a.m.
For some 30 minutes fourteen of them managed to telephone either loved ones or operators on the ground
Public relations man mark Bingham got through to his aunts home in California
This is Mark he began. I want to let you guys know that I love you in case. I don't see you again
Then I'm on United Airlines flight 93
It's being hijacked
Two other callers from the plane not only provided information
But also gleaned vital news from those they phoned
Tom Burnett chief operating officer for a medical devices firm made a number of brief calls to his wife Deena
Speaking quietly he asked her to contact the authorities and told her that a male passenger had been stabbed later
that he had died a
Woman perhaps a flight attendant was being held at knifepoint and the hijackers claimed they had a bomb
Jeremy Glick a
salesman for an Internet services company also managed to phone
in a long conversation with his wife
Liz Glick said the hijackers had put on these red headbands
They said they had a bomb they looked Iranian
The bomb was in a red box he said
The couple's told each other how much they loved each other
Glick said I don't want to die and his wife are him that he would not
She urged him to keep a picture of her and their 11 week old daughter in his head to think good thoughts
Burnett's wife who had been watching the news on television told him that two planes had crashed into the World Trade Center my god
He responded. It's a suicide mission
By the time he phoned a third time after news of the crash into the Pentagon she told him about that, too
Burnett seems to have been seated beside Glick and apparently related all this information to him
Were they to do nothing
The two men must have agreed they were sure to die anyway when the hijackers crashed the plane
They resolved to fight for their lives a
Group of us Burnett told his wife are getting ready to do something
I'm gonna take a vote click set on his call
There's three other guys as big as me, and we're thinking of attacking the guy with the bomb
So began the minutes of brave resistance the clearly-defined act of courage that has lived on in the national memory
Glick and others were equipped in more ways than one to confront the hijackers
Glick was 6 foot 1 and a former college judo champion
Burnett at six foot two had played quarterback for his high school football team
Mark Bingham was a huge man six foot four and at 31 still playing rugby a
Few years earlier he had fended off a mugger who had a gun
His mother got the impression as he talked from flight 93 that her son was talking confidently with a fellow passenger
She felt that maybe someone had organized a plan
At 9:42 a GTE
Verizon supervisor based near Chicago began handling a call from yet another powerfully-built flight 93 passenger
Todd Beamer a star Oracle software salesman was married with two sons and his wife was expecting
again
He first dialed his home number, but either failed to get through or thought better of it
instead
Explaining that he did not want to upset his pregnant wife
he asked the phone supervisor Lee Lisa Jefferson to pass along a
loving message
As they talked Beamer suddenly exclaimed shit. Oh my god, we're going down Jesus help us
From the passengers around Beamer came prolong shrieks of Terror
Then he said no wait we're coming back up I think we're okay now
Shaken Beamer asked Jefferson to say the Lord's Prayer with him our Father who art in heaven?
Just before Beamer and the operator had begun talking Cleveland lost Cleveland control lost flight 93's
transponder the signal that indicates an airplanes location and altitude that
9:55 the hijacker pilot set a navigational aid relating to the plane's direction
He was heading it indicated
for Washington DC
Jeremy Glick still on the phone to his wife Lyz said I know I could take this guy with the bomb
Then joking he had mentioned that the hijackers had knives. I still have my butter knife from breakfast
Todd Beamer continuing his conversation with the GTE
Supervisor Jefferson told her that he and a few others were getting together to jump the guy with the bomb
Was he sure that that was what he wanted to do, yes came the response I'm going to have to go out on faith I
Don't have much of a choice
The plane was flying erratically again
Operator Jefferson heard the sounds of an awful commotion raised voices more screams. Then are you guys ready?
and
todd beamers voice saying let's roll a
Phrase that in family life. He'd like to use to get his children moving
Okay Jeremy Glick called told his wife Liz I'm gonna do it
His wife told him he was strong and brave and that she loved him
Okay, he said again, I'm gonna put the phone down. I'm gonna leave it here, and I'm gonna come right back to it
Liz handed the phone to her father ran to the bathroom and gagged
Flight attendant Sandra Bradshaw was in the galley boiling water for the passengers to throw on the hijackers
On the phone to her husband she signed off quickly everyone's running up to first class. I've got to go bye
The cockpit voice recorder registered the moment the hijackers realized what was happening at just before
958 a hijacker asks is there something a fight?
There's a knock on the door followed by the sounds of fighting then in Arabic
Let's go guys. Allah is the greatest Allah is greatest. Oh guys Allah is greatest. Oh, Allah. Oh Allah
Oh the most gracious
Then loudly stay back a
Male voice a native english-speaking voice that Tom Burnett's wife has recognized as that of her husband
Is heard saying in the cockpit in the cockpit?
Followed by voice exclaiming in Arabic they want to get in here hold hold from the inside halt
Then from several English speakers in uniform unison hold the door and then from a single English speaker stop him falled
Repeatedly by sit down sit down then again from an English
Let's get them
Flight 93 now down to 5,000 feet had begun rolling left and right
Jeremy Glick father-in-law listening intently on the phone his daughter had handed to him now heard screams in the background
On the cockpit voice recorder there is the sound of combat continuing then in Arabic
There is nothing
Shall we finish it off
No, not yet
When they all come we finish it off
Then from Tom Burnett I am injured
The flight data recorder indicates that the plane pitched up and down climbed to 10,000 feet turned
Glicks father-in-law phone clap to his ear heard more shrieks muffled now like those of people
riding on a rollercoaster
In Arabic on the voice recorder oh
allah oh allah o
gracious
In english in the cockpit if we don't we'll die
In arabic up down up down up down
From a distance perhaps from Todd Beamer roll it
Crashing sounds then in Arabic Allah is the greatest Allah is the greatest is that it? I?
Mean shall we put it down
Yes put it in and pull it down
Cut off the oxygen cut off the oxygen cut off the oxygen up down up down up down
More violent noises for as long as a minute and then apparently from a native English speaker
Shut them off. Go go move move turn it up
Then an Arabic down down pull it down pull it down down
Apparently from an English speaker down push push push push push
In Arabic hey, hey give it to me give it to me give it to me give it to me
Give it to me give it to me
Intermittent loud air noise on the cockpit recorder
Moments later in Arabic Allah is the greatest Allah is the greatest Allah is the greatest Allah is the greatest?
Allah is the greatest
There sounds of further struggle and a loud shout from a native English speaker no
Two seconds later in Arabic in a whisper now
Allah is the greatest Allah is the greatest Allah is the greatest Allah is the greatest?
Jeremy Glick father-in-law still listening on the ground
Heard high-pitched screams coming over the line Glick had left open when he left the join to join the rush to the cockpit
Then wind
Sounds followed by banging noises as though the phone aboard the plane was repeatedly being banged on a hard surface
After that silence on the phone
Silence on the cockpit voice recorder
And that is an excerpt
From a book called the eleventh day which came out in 2011 by
Anthony summers and Robin Swan
And we all know what that silence meant
Flight 93 crashed into a field near the diamond T. Mine in Stoney Creek Township
Somerset County, Pennsylvania
killing 33 innocent passengers
Seven innocent crew members and four demonic hijackers
That day changed
My world then it changed our world the world as we knew it
And it commenced years and years and
Years of war that has cost so
Many lives and
At some point on this podcast
I'm sure we'll go into more details about the horrors of September 11th
new probably multiple podcasts, but for today I wanted to focus on
one
Aspect of one part of the life of one man on that flight the man named Jeremy Glick
Who
By all accounts was an amazing human being
Son and a husband and a father
But for those of us
Who fight or who
Train martial arts in general general something caught our ears when he heard about the heroics on flight 93
We heard that Jeremy Glick was a martial artist that he was a wrestler, and then he was a judoka
And as a wrestler
he wasn't
competitive
All-state wrestler for Saddle River Dei school in northern, New Jersey, and if you know anything about New Jersey wrestling
It's an extremely competitive wrestling State
And beyond that as a judo player
Glick was an American national collegiate judo champion
While he was a student at the University of Rochester and
In September of 2008
Seven years after the incident September 11th there was a memorial ceremony
At the crash site in Pennsylvania and
the United States Judo Association
placed a granite stone
There as a memorial with an inscription on it
And
the inscription reads the United States Judo Association
promote promoted Jeremy Glick
to the highest rank of black belt
for living the principle of
Judo
Mutual welfare and benefit
Sacrificing his life for our country
September 11th
Living the principle of Judo and that's a bold statement
It indicates something very powerful and very meaningful
and as a
Patriot and as a martial artist and specifically as a jiu-jitsu practitioner
Which is where judo was derived from I wanted to explore a little deeper into the principles of Judo to see
What we can learn from it?
And I don't want to go into the full details of
Explaining the relationships between jiu-jitsu and judo, but it is a very close relationship
It was one of J Goro
Pinos top students and Kay knows the creator of judo
But my eda that brought
jiu-jitsu to Brazil from Japan and Inter Douce jujitsu to Carlos and a Leo Gracie
And that's the beginning of Brazilian jiu-jitsu as we know it today, and my eating even called it jiu-jitsu
he didn't call it judo and
From what I understand at that time
Even Kano had not been actually calling it judo in Japan. He hadn't renamed it yet
he was still calling it jiu-jitsu and some people were calling it Kano jiu-jitsu or
Kodokan jujitsu, but jiu-jitsu especially Brazilian jiu-jitsu is without question rooted in judo and
If you trace it back just a little bit further judo is also rooted back into jiu-jitsu
That's where judo came from judo came from jiu-jitsu
In mixed in with all that there's all kinds of
evolution and there's changes and there's politics, and there's history, but there's that thread that ties them all together and that
thread can be recognized in
Many of the principles that are shared both in judo and in jiu-jitsu
The same principles that played a role in Jeremy glicks attitude on that
Clear sunny September day
And
Perhaps we can all learn something from those principles and to look at those principles
I thought it would be best to go
to the source
and I
Have a book called mind over muscle. That is
It's it's a compilation of writings from jigoro kano and
Cato was a very interesting person
He was a he was an educator
He was a pioneer in sports. He worked with the Olympic Committee. He was a jiu-jitsu practitioner
eventually founded judo, and he founded the most famous judo school the original judo school the Kodokan and
The book like I said as you can tell by the title it's a compilation of different sources of his writings
And there's a little bit of overlap and repeat, and I'll do a little bit of that
But what I like about it is it gives a good
overall view of the ideas and the vision that Kano had for judo
So I
know there's a lot of Judo practitioners out there and obviously a lot of jiu-jitsu practitioners out there that listen to the podcast and
everyone knows that these two are closely related and sometimes there's
I guess you'd say
tension between the two
sometimes
But
The fact of the matter is they're so closely related that it's it'd be more
It'd be more intelligent instead of look for the tension between the two to find where the two can complement each other
So here we're going to the book and once again
The book is mind over muscle writings from the founder of Judo
jigoro kano
And here we go to start it off the purpose of jujitsu
See you interesting that he starts this off. It's talking about jujitsu
They're not even talking about judo yet the original purpose of jujitsu was to practice a method of combat
While combat may have been at the core of jujitsu practice it
Also had the related goals of physical education and mental training
There is little dispute that because training to fight involves moving the body in various ways jiu-jitsu indirectly became a form of physical education
But for the same reason it also became a method for training the mind
all forms of combat required ingenuity and
The use of various tricks and devices so all forms of combat all
forms of combat
this is important because
When if you're if you're a a soldier you're a marine or your own airman right now
We're talking about everything that you do and I'll tell you what if you're a business person we're talking about what you're doing to
all forms of combat require ingenuity and the use of various tricks and devices
So in the course of jujitsu training the mind is unconsciously trained in many ways
Courage composure composure and other traits that are beneficial in life can also be developed now. I'll tell you what this is important because
People ask me a lot like
You know how did you figure all this stuff out Jocko, but people ask me that mmm and
You know I always try and explain
You know like it was a long course and I was in the military for a long time
And I had an open mind, and I listened to paid attention to the people that were leading me
And I paid attention the good ones and I paid attention to the bad ones
But I'll tell you if I didn't I jiu-jitsu opened my mind up and did these things and again
unconsciously like I started to perceive things the way that I was learning jiu-jitsu and
That's why I've got some I got you know
I've got friends, and I've gotten in jiu-jitsu over the years
And you can tell and I don't know what makes some people get the bug and some people don't get the bug
but if you get the bug and you start to think in a jujitsu mindset, then you'll
It'll really open up your mind now that being said
There's some people that are heavily into jiu-jitsu, but they don't apply jiu-jitsu to the the other aspects of the life
Which is a big mistake?
It's a big mistake
You got to apply it both ways
And I think that's one of the things that that Kano was trying to do with judo was to
Ensure that you did that to ensure that his students did that hmm?
All right
Back to the book it was my belief that
With a few improvements jiu-jitsu could become a comprehensive method of physical education
intellectual training and moral education I
Therefore spent several years developing my ideas and finally established the Kodokan judo
I did this by thoroughly researching the jujitsu that it existed up until the time up until that time as much as possible
Keeping what I felt should be kept discarding what I felt should be discarded
Thoroughly studying the techniques and theories and establishing them in a way
That would be most applicable to today's society. It's not even talking about just combat he's talking about like he not talk about fighting
He's like talking about applying these things to society
so there's a little bit of
Yeah, I think he was young when he did this too. He established the Kodokan at a very young age
I want to say he was like 22 years old. He was really young so he studied you did too
Thought some things were good about it. Thought some things were bad about it and said I'm gonna make my own deal mm-hmm
Now here
We talk a little bit here there were there were various reasons why I chose not to use the term jiu-jitsu which described
What was ordinarily practiced and instead employ the name judo?
The main reason was that dough the dough part of Judo it meanswe
Is the major force there's a major focus of what the Kodokan teaches whereas Jitsu skill is?
incidental I
Also wanted to make it clear that judo was a means of embarking on the way
So he saw this as like a complete a complete life system right not just fighting
This is the way judo is the way for him and that's why he instead of calling it Jiu Jitsu we called it
You know not not take techniques, but like the way
Back to the book when we talk about jujitsu today
People often think of a technique in which one does only?
Dangerous things such as choking an opponent and bending his joints or even in extreme cases killing him
Essentially we think of something that is harmful to the whole book to the body while offering no benefits
True Jiu Jitsu does not espouse this in particular the Kodokan judo. I devised never involves doing anything dangerous
I cannot stress enough that what I advocate is far from a violent or dangerous sport
Now
Sure I understand the principle there, but
Just so everyone knows
Judo doesn't play around you know if you've if you've gone with a high-level judo player
You are getting thrown hard and aggressively on to your
Head yeah, it's it's a brutal sport. It's it's very aggressive. Yeah. Do you think that that's how or that's what because?
When it comes down to the essence it's like and this is just me totally guessing where judo
As it is now. It's like okay. The goal is basically to put the guy in his back
That's it put him down on the ground
Not to hit him not to knock him down put him on the ground right this kind of seems
Okay
That's really violent that's kind of the little friendly competition put them on the ground now with any competitive situation
Oh guys you're gonna get after it, and it slowly just evolves into all these crazy things. It doesn't evolve it
Escalates even just the whole way so even can
Consider like basketball for example the goal put that ball in that basket. That's it you go from here
Come close laughs whatever, then you get this competitive drive these people athletic abilities all this stuff now
It's turning into weird slam dunks now bright
You didn't have to slam dunk that thing, but it's still the same thing put in the ball
You know and the thing that's in this weird aggressive. I guess yeah, I guess yeah, I guess a layup
Compared to a
tomahawk slam dog right yeah, and if you compare a
Let's say some sort of a basic takedown compared to like a full
Upon the slide yeah, I could see your I could see your comparison seem say there's an escalation yeah
And then his mind he was like hey look at this is just a takedown
Yeah, you tell that to a 21 year old judo competitor. That's got you in there
takedown you
Yeah, exactly right just like you know a basket a basket. You know oh, yeah
He made that basket no, but he slammed on you, and you know embarrass you in front of it
You know like it goes into this whole different realm, but the essence is still there though is the basket?
Just to take that yeah all right here
We go back to the book the organization of Kodokan judo is basically the same today as it was
When I established it, but at that time when explaining judo, I divided it into three parts
It's use as a fighting method martial art as a training method physical education and as a method of mental training
Including the development of the intellect and morals and the application of the principles of Judo to everyday life
See this is again. This is what's interesting to me is and he said it was subconscious like I subconsciously
especially in the beginning with jiu-jitsu
And I'll tell you was beyond just
me applying
Jiu-jitsu to like my life and to what I had learned about combat I also took what I had learned about
Combat and applied that into jiu-jitsu right like III said oh, yeah, you know this is like when you flank someone
Right yeah, but even even when I first learned
one of the one of the biggest wake-up calls that you get early in jujitsu is like oh
What I need to do is attack your neck and when you defend your neck I take your arm right. That's a flank, right?
That's just a straight up flank. That's that's a game-changer like that's a complete game changer when you realize that
That's a complete game changer well
There's a seal buddy mine that had been training when I first started out he'd been training for like a year
No, but he'd been training off and on kind of
bits and pieces and so then I started training hardcore like everyday yeah, so after like
Two weeks like literally two weeks
I went trained with him, and I and I got him like a bunch of times and I was all pumped up and
And I said to him I said hey, you know what you the mistake that you're making is you're trying
You're going for my arm, and I know you're going for an arm, and I'd know how to defend that
I think you got to go for something else and then like a week later
We rolled again, and he got me did what I told him to do to me. Yeah. I was like oh dang
Oh dang, so that was a big wake-up call that's a big no-no. It's it's a revelation when you realize
Oh, you've got to do you got a set that you gotta fight the person yeah, that's what you have to do
Yeah, big wake-up call so crazy to see two people rolling and all they're doing is flanking each other. Oh, you're flanking the flag
Yeah
But what's interesting is as I started working with like leaders and teaching my leadership?
How important the idea of what flanking is from a leadership and a human interaction perspective?
Another such. Did you gotta flank people you want to attack that ego, yeah?
All right back to the book two methods of instruction are used
Kata, which is a form and randori which is free practice? It's what we call in the jujitsu rolling and
When establishing the Kodokan I employed a method that emphasized randori and by which cada naturally came to be understood
During randori practice. This is rather so he focused on rolling a lot
When he established kota comp a test. This is very interesting randori
Rolling trains rolling its rolling. It's good to remember that yeah use it
This is rather like teaching composition
Without using a grammar book or teaching the basis of grammar while teaching how to write an essay
So this is like hey man write this down. Are you gonna make some Corrections and like that's that's basically rolling live right now
When there are only a few people undergoing the training this was not a problem
But the number of beginners gradually increased
And it became impossible to teach cada at the same time as randori so a few years after I established Kodokan judo
I created 15 kata four throws and ten kata for combat
Called kimi no kata, which meant forms of self-defense so he realized he couldn't teach the same way. He couldn't teach the masses
So what you know? That's
That's a big change right. There's a big big change for anyone. That's not into martial arts
There's a big big difference between rolling and learning kata and matter fact. We make fun of kata right I'm not saying
That's a good thing. Yeah, but we shouldn't say we completely make fun of it, but like I'll see Dean and
Let's say he's I can tell he's tired. You know he's looking all worn out mm-hm, and I'll see you. Oh, yeah
Hey, what's going on? Man you want to train some kata today meaning?
Hey
Are we just gonna go through the motions?
Not axe drill you know no we're gonna train right so that when I say make fun
Yeah, you don't make fun of it because because what we call kata basically in jujitsu we call it drilling
Yeah, right, you're gonna drill this drill drill drill which drilling is part of winning
You got to drill to win right Andre Galvao drill just make killers drillers make killer there. It was all those things that
Being said we all know
If you do nothing, but drill you're not gonna be able to pull these moves off going live and this with the old
traditional martial arts
That was all cotton and all kata will get you nowhere
That's when the guys when you saw that the 90s when the jutsu invasion happened
You know the guy would try his
12-point strike kata
Method against a blue belt in jujitsu the blue belt will do a sloppy duggle double leg take him down the ground and choke him
out
cuz they rolled live they did randori so
You have to have balance but you got a trained live randori and at the same time you've got a drill, too
so
Be careful don't do too much. I want
Seems like the drilling helps you get a hold of what you do with your body
and then the brandori the light the rolling yeah, gives you a
You know controller or better skill in dealing with other people off rider so and that's what Jesus is both
You know where you can kind of and you're gonna get
You're gonna get
Reactions that are different right right and this is the same thing
This is the same thing like when I was training guys in the teams like
You could teach them the basics of how to enter a room and then how to move down a hallway
But as soon as you put
Another person they're going against them yeah
is like
different things happen yeah
Different things are gonna happen. You got to be ready for it, so you have to go a lot
I-i've told I told you this story before but when when I first started playing basketball
And my coach, I had the old school he had the old school Hoosiers coach right yeah
You know the old school you seen the movie Hoosiers. No. Oh dad
So in Hoosiers the guy's old school coach like hey know you're not even allowed to shoot were defense defense defense real internals drill drill
Drill, we never scrimmaged and the first time I played in a real game. It was the first time
I played a real game
I
went down the court and like called the play and expected to be able to execute the play that had run the little pattern and
The the other point guard just picked me off. I was in 7th or 8th grade
He just picked off every pass
I threw I was just because I'd never done randori on the basketball court never scrimmage never played
You know you got to balance those two
All right
Next back to the book next I would like to briefly discuss free practice involving throwing and grappling techniques
Which I will refer to by their Japanese names
So the two Japanese names, and he's going to use her
Khatami Wazza and
Naga Ozzy now now walls it means technique, right?
and
You probably knew that a lot of us we a lot of us in jiu-jitsu we talked about or we we want we know about
Judah we talked about nawaz ax
and any
Waa-waa, za Nawaz it means ground work. That's what it means mat work basically is what I mean. I think I think
The end he actually means like laying down or sleeping or something like that so it means you're down on the ground
Khatami Wazza is the Khatami walls it is like the grappling part, but you're not necessarily
You're not necessarily
Laying down in all grappling positions, so that's why they call it, Khatami Wazza
But but Nagi Wazza is the throws alright so here we go back to the book when I was training
I practiced Khatami Wazza quite a bit but after coming to appreciate Naga Wazza
I came to believe that Naga waz he should be
Emphasized in the technical training aspects of Judo this does not mean I considered Khatami Wazza to be useless of course
But I stress practicing Naga Wazza first
Followed, then by khatami Wallis's so he focused on the throwing techniques
This is because doing Khatami Wazza first hinders progress in Naga Wazza
While it makes sense that learning Naga. Wasa first makes it easier to remember Khatami Wazza as at a later stage
when I established Kodokan I
Encouraged the practice of Naga Wazza precisely for that reason as a result at that time a great
great number of experts in Naga Wazza were fostered in the early years the Kodokan as a
result of emphasizing Naga Wazza, however Khatami Wazza gradually became neglected
That's very interesting so anyone that knows anything about judo, and Jiu Jitsu one of the biggest differences is in jiu-jitsu
We focused small town on ground work too much
Well you could say too much right because there's there's there's jiu-jitsu people that don't know how to take someone down and that's very problematic
so
He's saying that hey. He focused on that and you can kind of hear what he's saying so
if you
It's real easy to ignore the stand-up when you realize how effective the ground game is and you also realize that if you if you
understand how to take the person down
then you're gonna get in good positions and all that so he just kind of leaned in that direction and
Says that it ends up getting a little bit neglected and also if you don't know the rules of Judo
Emphasize the takedowns because the rules of Judo if I take you down if I throw you with a Nippon, which means
Something some other body part other than your feet touches the ground before your feet do it during the throw I win automatically
Instant win it's like a submission and so because of that they practice a lot to stand up
Yeah, whereas in jiu-jitsu you can get thrown ten times?
And you can still catch person in a triangle you win you on the ground doesn't matter? Yeah?
And you can get pinned in judo too if you get held down for thirty seconds about thirty
It's thirty Seconds on on your back you get pinned you lose. Yeah, that doesn't happen in jiu-jitsu
You can have someone across side on you for four or seven eight minutes. Yeah, just you haven't even moved
You know you didn't lose, and you sneak out of there and grab a little camera and get the victory sir
All right back to look at the Kodokan
We study and practice techniques with the purpose of using mental and physical energy most of fit most
Effectively in order to achieve one's gold no matter what the endeavor which is the basic principle of Judo?
And he's gonna talk about this a ton the basic principle of Judo is like efficiency so those in training
Do not merely know, but this is so important those in training
Do not merely imitate the actions of the master or practice without understanding the reasons behind
What they are doing?
But rather consider the methods and train in accordance with detailed principles
For that reason what once took five or six years to achieve can now be accomplished in three years
This is huge in jiu-jitsu, and I saw this transition take place when I started learning jiu-jitsu we learned moves
Now everyone teaches concepts. I mean you still teach moves, but if you don't know the principles of them
and it's the same thing when I was teaching guys in the teams like you teach them a
Maneuver on the battlefield if you can learn the mechanics of the move on the battlefield
But if you don't understand why those mechanics are important, then it doesn't make you don't even have you don't have it
Don't get it same thing in the business world you can tell someone like hey
Here's what you should tell your subordinates right now. Yeah, but that technique
Can use it and it'll work, okay, but that's nothing compared to saying
Here's why it's important that you tell your subordinates this thing and here's how you want to lead them
That's what gives them the game is when they understand the principles, yeah
Yeah, that's why those introductory courses are so critical yeah, and I'm talk about jujitsu, FC
where
You get a new guy first day guy
And he jumps in a class and the class they're teaching the you know the mechanics of a certain move
Meanwhile everyone in the class. They're not first day people
They know the concepts behind it, but they come in and it's just it's just a different language. It doesn't stick yeah
Yes, yeah, it's like trying to teach someone if you if you if you had a non-native English speaker
And you walk in and you're gonna teach him of
You know a vocabulary word. Yeah, which is like you know audacious right?
He there's no context to put that in that's not the word to teach him
He doesn't even know how to say I yeah, so when you start teaching someone at home or Plata
Yeah, and they don't understand when I'm walk are is they're gonna have issues. Yeah, that's like you know fundamentals
Do you want ketchup with that teach someone who doesn't know any English do you want kids with teach them that and then send them?
Out he doesn't know when to use that you know. I know how to say it well
You're not just gonna roll into the post-office and be like hey. Do you want ketchup with that it doesn't make sense? No, it's unusable
Back to the book various records and accounts have been passed down over the ages with regard to the true meaning of jiu-jitsu
Then he's talking about the actual word jiu-jitsu
But few of them are accurate
It can be said though that the name apparently derived from the expression jus yoko go oshizu
Which can be trained Lee translated as?
softness controls hardness
This expression needs closer attention
Let's assume I have an opponent who possesses power vowed to the value of ten whereas
I must face this opponent with power only to the value of seven
When my opponent thrusts at me with all of his energy it follows that if I resist I will be overcome
Even if I expend all my power
If however rather than resist my more powerful opponent, I adjust and adapt to his energy and pull back
He will fall forward under the strength of his own attack his power of 10 will become merely a power of three
And he will stumble and lose his balance
I will not be pulled off balance and can pull away maintain my stance and retain my original power of seven
In short resisting a more powerful opponent will result in your defeat whilst
Adjusting you to and evading your opponent's attack will cause him to lose his balance his power will be reduced and you will defeat him
This can apply whenever the relative values of power thus making it possible for weak opponents to beat
significantly stronger ones
There you go. Yes, sir, that's the way it works
Can it level 10 beat a level looking a level one beat a level 10? That's tricky
There's that. There's a there's a point right yeah, there's a point where
Like yeah, yeah, because there's like even that what he's talking about I like how he did it in numbers like how he did that?
but
The reality is like that
It's again cool to have the numbers, but it's not they're not absolute numbers
There's a lot of gray area in there so the idea is to take his tan and use
almost like using part of his tan for on top of your seven because you're going the same way but
It's like how much of that 10. Are you gonna use if you're one you better. You'd be using nine. You know master
Yeah, you gotta be using a lot of his number you know, but now this is one of those things
this is one of those things that I
subconsciously learned from jujitsu, and I applied it all the time especially in dealing with
Relationships, and I've talked about it here a million times if like hey don't attack the ego
Don't attack the strong point right yeah, that's just complete
Just just to complete jujitsu mentality
That's what it is and and it works if you attack that strong point
son zou hardiwar 2500 years old if you
Attack the different heavily defended position you're not gonna win if you go against a power of 10
And you've only got a power seven you're not gonna win not gonna. Even if you use full power
Even if all power in fact it's gonna be worse for you. Especially the other guy knows
He's gonna use that seven he's gonna use that in addition to his 10
He's gonna beat you with a 17 to zero yeah
And that actually backs up or kind of refers back to your point where Kenna when you say Kenna level one beat a level ten
so a level if they both know jujitsu or judo then you know it's way because he knows the same thing as you but
you know if you're
Nine if you're better than the guy for an eye, and then you know your friend start to go up
This doesn't washer no doubt no doubt about that, but I think that's where people they get jammed up where they're like hey
What do I thought size didn't matter in jujitsu oh?
Yeah, if everyone's doing jujitsu of course size matters. Just like a decent gonna matter
Just like how tall you it matters how strong Lin matters when you all know the Jiu Jitsu
Yeah, when you that's like a dude said the other day
Jiu Jitsu is not important as important in the UFC as it was the guy that just beat for doom
big tall badass guy from Russia Cal cough or something
Sorry, bro
he
But he said hey, it's not as important anymore and the fact that but you're right
You know why it's not as important because everybody knows is it so yeah
It's not as important to go you roll in there without knowing any jujitsu you're gonna get ya submit it you feel employee yes
Yeah, yeah exactly
All right back to the book. There's a popular parable that goes thus a
Jujitsu
Which means a jiu-jitsu practitioner was grabbed by a sumo wrestler at that point that jujitsu?
Said you're a sumo wrestler yet, you can't grab any tighter than that
Angered the sumo wrestler attempted to adjust his grip as he did so he loosened it slightly at that moment that jujitsu
Quickly lowered his body and escaped from the sumo refs loose grip
All right now there's another we're gonna talk about this theory
called Sirocco
Sajin, that's you and I apologize to everyone that speaks Japanese. I'm sorry Tim Ferriss
I'm sorry
I should have waited for you to come and do this with me so you could correct me, but here here
We go one's mental and physical energy must be used most effectively
In order to achieve a certain goal
That is to say one must apply the most effective method or technique for using the mind and body
if we use the term Ciriaco
For one's mental and physical energy this should be expressed to Yoko Susan
Casio which means best use of one's energy we can shorten this
simply to Ciriaco Zegna, which means maximum efficiency
Maximum efficiency this means that no matter what the goal no matter what the goal in order to achieve it you
Must put your mental and physical energy to work in the most effective manner
This is like common sense right, but how often are we wasting energy?
How often are we wasting energy? We're wasting energy all the time
Back to the book when I was a child I learned the jiu-jitsu of the past
However the dad jiu-jitsu had no basic principle. I learned various methods from one teacher
He taught me how to place my hips and pull to throw an opponent and how to choke someone
But he did not teach me anything about what principles were involved or how to apply those principles
But that's I think that's the same that as
Jiu-jitsu hit America, I think everyone was learning like that like here's how you choke someone, but you weren't learning the system
as
I studied further I found that one one teacher taught differed from a what another taught
There was no basis upon which to decide which one was correct
That was the reason I began to make a thorough study of jiu-jitsu now what I would say about that is
You don't need to decide which one is correct
Like when you learn an armbar from one person you learn a lot armbar from someone else
You're gonna learn
Good things from both of them
Neither one of them is correct and one of them might be correct in this
Situation or with this body style and the other ones corrected in different situations the different body style I think
if we look to knose
Personality traits like he's a guy. That's real or girly
And I think that's yeah he's every a guy like Jordan Peterson people would put him in the high
conscientious and high a high and orderly
That's a very orderly person and so for him like there's a right answer, and there's a wrong answer
And I think you see that in judo and that's why judo is much more
disciplined
Highly disciplined like go to a judo competition. There are no yelling. It's Gregorio jujitsu competition. It's mayhem
Yeah, yeah right and they've tried to tighten that up like they try and make it less crazy, but they haven't succeeded
Juju's crazy do competitions are crazy judo competitions are not like that. Yeah, bro. Did you see there's a clip a-doodle clip on online?
Wherever I saw it
But it's a clip and so this guy wins right the real
Dramatic win like maybe he wasn't supposed to win her honor maybe he's an upset maybe not or maybe it was a finals
I don't know, but it was a real dramatic win he wins and he's like you know how they yell
And they be all happy whether he did that any kind of stood over the guy
Oh, just a second like I split like pretty short
DQ DQ yeah, just like that so legit like men in jiu-jitsu MMA. You see that all day, yeah
see, that's that's the that's
One of the reasons I wanted to talk about this is like that is a quality thing
You know it's - and I guess this is different on the east coast or west coast
The East Coast like one of my buddies Jill
He came and watched some wrestling with me with some high school wrestling and they Pat Africa with it
They penalize people like oh, no you're not allowed to do that like they're strict when you get done when you get done
Wrestling you just got pinned you get up you get to the senator mat you put your hand out to shake hands
That's it yeah. They'll complain to the ref. There's no this other crap
No you do what you're supposed to do
And that's awesome because that you know what that teaches people teach people how to control their emotions, yeah
Yeah, I remember in Pop Warner. You know my only frame of reference was watching football on TV NFL
spike in the ball doing the ickey shuffle back in my day, Akina Mikey woods anyway back did it um and
So you know we play Pop Warner football my first year?
I knew that our coach was super disciplined
Like the kind where you had to everyone had to wear high white socks white shirt like a real discipline
And I see how the teams and they difficult issues all this stuff. That's all I knew though so it was clear
You couldn't spike the ball. You couldn't do any dance or whatever you give the ball to the ref
That's that's it when you make a touchdown
So we played this
team
That will remain nameless, and they go they did you don't want to bring up the old rivalries?
Babymaker actually was a team from out of town acts huh and
They he spiked the ball little kids spiked the ball and does the thing or whatever share flag. It's it's a penalty
Oh, you actually even in colleges like that. Oh, right. I don't know yeah in college
Football's like that you can do you can do more for sure
But yeah Pop Warner anything you do anything you you throw the ball you
Put your hands up for too long if you put your hands up for too long after you make it touchdown
That's a penalty all that sports been like condo. That's legit right. I think so especially as little kids
I think so especially even as big kids yeah
When you're a professional
Um this is what he said when you're a professional football player you can and you make a touchdown
Something about like that's your job or whatever so yeah, you have the right to be happy about it
That's kind of but when I think about it. Now. It's like shoot if you're professional you focus on your profession
Do you think so I?
Guess it's whatever your philosophy is
And you could say like UFC. I mean it's really cool. It's so much cooler when
Someone wins and they just are like check. Yeah, it's like know what you're yeah
We're just go out there and just destroy someone that just comes like yeah. Thanks. Good match. Yeah, that is true
I know we all want to see the high
band jump on top of the cage sells tickets in blah blah blah
But there's nothing better than just a cold-blooded killer that just comes out and and you're it's interesting sometimes fighters do it
I think I was watching cowboy Cerrone or the bait like knock some grounds walked away like it was nothing
Yeah, yeah, I do this every single night. Yeah. Yeah, like yeah, yeah, but but they don't show that clip or like Mark Hunt
Yeah, yeah mark hunt just doesn't walk away. Not now just knocks dude. I just walks away
I guess yeah, can I get my piece of chicken now? I'm hungry yeah
But the reason that those are so cool like phaidor. That's great example by the way where he's just no
He's not getting hyped up. No the fight. He's not act up afterwards
You know no emotion is this cold yeah that that
Gets that seems more appealing because it's in contrast to all the hype all the high more this guy get hyped up and whatever
So if everyone was like that
He would be like it would still would be cool
But even then I'm probably just comparing it to like how I know it can't knock a hybrid Conor McGregor gets pumped
I mean yeah, exactly right so
You know it. There's a there's a dichotomy yeah, there's a dichotomy. I think the preferred method though is cold-blooded
Yeah, but when you and this is really what it is and this goes for the NFL to benefit for sure
Yeah, um it's it's a show you gotta remember
Yeah, that's a show exactly right so in that means to for the NFL where we fit
Just go sit around and watch old phaidor fight, so you know Sakuraba was kind of like Sakuraba didn't celebrate
Yeah, horse. Yes. Uh Carrabba was pretty cool, too. Yeah
I totally cold-blooded
But just so you say man like Connor and like these guys who do put on a show that's kind of cool, too
All right back to the book in the end I learned from various teachers in various schools
but when one method of instruction differed from another I had difficulty determining how to resolve those differences as I studied further I
Came up with the principles. I've described in order to achieve your goals. You must put your energy to use most effectively again
I'll just say that you don't have to choose like this one's right and this one's wrong
You need to absorb both those methodologies and have them both in your toolkit cause you might need them mmm
You know say yeah, I don't like having the metric
wrench
Sockets and the you know oh, yeah, yeah, and the other one you got the other ones got a need that
one the other one you come across a
bolt
That's metric. Yeah, you better be ready for that
Here's that here's some stuff. That's
interesting
Calisthenics are generally based on physiology and Anatomy
So they do not result in the development of unbalanced body nor are they harmful to the internal organs
But they are not without without drawbacks because each individual movement has no meaning and because
calisthenics have no secondary benefits they are
Uninteresting calisthenics are widely used in Japan and abroad but few students continue to do them after grades graduating from school
This is because they are a meaningless form of exercise and not of any practical use no matter how much they are taught
If people do not continue to practice them. There is very very little value in teaching them
Cold-blooded cold-blooded dig it
So what should be done?
We need to adopt the strong points of calisthenics and compensate for their shortcomings of course there are various possibilities
But for now I have come up with these two ideas first the first is calisthenics that incorporate training for the defensive for the defense
against attack so the first one's like you come up with
Calisthenics that represent movements that are from fighting right so like a classic is a sprawl sprawl. Yeah
Go do some sprawls. You want to get in good shape me
I go do some sprawls incorporate that in one of the workouts. I used to do with my kids when they were little
Is they'd have to do five sprawls and max pull-ups every minute on the minute for five minutes
Just five minutes see how many pull-ups
They could get to do five sprawls and use many pull-ups as you can to see
How many this is a brutal workout go try that yeah?
No, you don't need to be an eight-year-old kid you can be a 46 year old man. Go hit that for five minutes
Yeah, five sprawls max pull-ups go but he's a good workout for kids
Yeah, but legit, but anyway sprawls
That's an exercise where it debt reflects exactly the movement that you would do on the mat now here
We go back to the book my other idea could be called dance style mm-hmm
And I'm not gonna get into he talks about he's basically saying like hey you come up with dance moves that are fun
that work your body and
what I thought of immediately when I when I thought when I read that I was like thinking about all the all the I
Guess is b-boys and breakdancing the same thing be bullies do breakdancing so it's like judo and judoka
So b-boy is okay breakdance, so like a tenth planet guys a bunch of the tenth planet guys came from the breakdancing background
Yeah, and they have the physical attributes the flexibility the strength from that and it turns out to be awesome for jiu-jitsu
Yeah, so there's a good and you can find out with gymnastics people too like yeah like gymnastics. Here's a skill
But I guess his point is in his mind
That's now fun somehow see in my mind like it not fun
What the breakdancing like to me doing a breakdance move compared to doing a push-up?
Yeah, you'd rather do the push-up well, I mean there's not a huge difference right. Yeah, yeah, yeah, breakdown is pretty fun
You said you don't want us young did you have parachute pants? Yeah?
Ritchie Martinez and Gio Martinez yeah, yeah
Yeah, well they're there they're badass ters
Did you guys and their b-boys yeah and that that is what they attribute their feels their skills?
Developing so quickly so quickly and when you when you think about it
and it's absolutely true because you think of
Breakdancing moves like how you can spin on your back and do it like all this stuff like to spin on your back
You know these guys who go inverted do all this stuff where they're really good control over their like spatial body
Yeah, you know so these breakdancing guys. They come in with level 10 love that you know and
Well wrestlers obviously come in at a high level gym to anyone
That's really good at gymnastics has that same kind of awareness, and they have some crazy strength
yeah, so yeah, maybe that is a good thing for the for the judo players to come up with some kind of a
Good dance a dance
Well what about capoeira?
Cuz Kappa what it was it was a fighting disguised as dancing. Yes, sir
Yeah, you know it was it was the African slaves in Brazil yeah, and if you notice
I know it's cuz they did it told. It's not a thesis
What do you call it like anyway thing in college, but they did a thing on college in Kappa water uncommon
Yeah, okay, and so I'm gonna go into a whole long thing but good if you go early capoeira was only legs
No, you know why because they a lot of the time
They'd be tied up hands behind their back so that yes, so they came up with this fighting system distend disguise
It is dancing to use against their captors mm-hmm. It's very interesting that is interesting
Be boys people have wait a couple other guys Jeff Higgs went from jiu-jitsu to capoeira mm-hmm
Fabio Fabio Santos our old teacher was like Higgs
You're the only person. That's ever gone from jiu-jitsu. He kept training jiu-jitsu. Yeah
incorporated capoeira yeah even
Right community does the same thing I think he no no I think he
Now most people would find, Kappa wedding all that seems cool, but then you get choked out. You're like I'm gonna learn
Yeah, yeah that goes man. You ever see note like a cop with like a
Performance or whatever man. There's this it's gymnastics. It's whatever you wanna. Call it like this yeah, man. It's really impressive
It's always like he'll deal dude
And I'm referring to this guy that you said he'd put on a couple of show every Wednesday at this club
I worked at in Hawaii and
So he do these like flips and somersaults and stuff like that, and it looks like oh he messed up that somersault
But that was part of the move see I'm saying so he instead of sticking the landing
He doesn't stick the landing
he rolls into the next movie and also it's this big string of just real fluid mist it's kind of captivating I
Can see how that would benefit?
Okay noted yeah
All right back to the book. There's no need to reject traditional form of exercise those who enjoy them subdue them
My doctrine is very simple highly recommend. What is best without rejecting things of the past so I do not
particularly oppose Japan's conventional methods of physical education
But I would like to devise the best form of physical education and recommend as many people as possible take it up thus
Resulting in a form of physical education that at the same time achieves worthwhile goals that is cool
right
Like that's one of the coolest things about jujitsu is you are getting in shape and you?
Are learning how to choke people out which is a really beneficial fig and then for all the people that say well
I want to start jiu-jitsu, but I need to get in shape first
No, you don't you just need to start jiu-jitsu and you'll get in shape along the way
Back to the book the prosperity of a nation can be hoped for only with an energized populace that
Vitality and that vitality depends on the mental and physical training of the people
The powerful nations of the world have explored every avenue in order to build their national strength
And they are paying particular attention to physical education and endeavoring to promote vitality of their citizens through their own unique methods
Well, that sounds good, and it was true at one time but in America right now. We're getting pretty weak on physical education
Need to step it up
Step it up you ever seen that video of the old school. They would did some experimental
gym class somewhere in California
And like the crazy ops courses like in the maybe the 40s or the 50s
And they had crazy obstacle courses. They had this and like every kid looked like a complete beast
And you're like yeah, why wouldn't you do that? Why wouldn't gym class at school?
Be an hour long of hardcore physical putting out. Mm. Why would it not be that way right?
Yeah, you know why cuz people I am, but that's insulting to my child because he's not a great athlete
Well your kids not gonna be a better athlete if they don't start training art right so like was it get in the game
Yeah, I agree, so what what is it though? The kid the kid like okay? We're gonna
Do push-ups today right and you know Johnny did a hundred push-ups meanwhile?
I can only do two so I feel bad that messes up my self-esteem
I don't want to put you on the spot, and you know what we're just gonna not do push-ups. Yeah in fact
You know we're gonna do for PE. Weave baskets basket weaving yeah, but even isn't the isn't the whole grading system
I know good a little different thing, but isn't the whole grading system in school like that anyway. Hey Johnny over there gotta a yeah
Yeah, it is right now. Yeah, but you know there's the universities for sure that have like well. There's no grades here
Yeah, because we don't this is no matter grade
Yeah
actually the like no actually your school becoming you know what you don't know it makes my kids about my kids will be like I
Got a I had a 96 on the math test and I'm like what was the class average
Who did you lose to anyone and they're like
No
If everyone got a 96 I don't care. You know your average. I don't know maybe you should care
Maybe you should know maybe you should be impressed with the teacher the teacher is so good
That they when they test these kids these kids
Score almost perfect on the tests on the material that they touch thing that's one good teacher right there. Yeah well
I'd be impressed to the teacher
But I wouldn't be impressed with my kid if they just got the same as everyone else. They need to step it up
What if they don't mess it up? What if they all got hundreds ok they got a hundred okay like still not impressed
Well, it's a good job, but I'm not impressed. I'm impressed hundred perfect score on a test
My head it my wife. My little daughter will come home
She'll be like dad. I got a 94 on the math test. It'll be like which one. Did you miss?
The color she did a great job
I'm not gonna lie to her. Whatever that is a good job
All right, okay? We'll leave it. You know. It's funny as I know you're really not like that cuz I see
You know what's funny is I I do say that to my kids. Yeah with this joking, but it is hell it is fun
Yeah, like you're like a tower put the one where at my house the pool. Everyone's jumping in the pool doing their dives
Yeah, and you're like
It's like joking Jocko. You can totally tell you're like good dive, but I want to see improvement in this area
And this it's like over it is good. I see what you're doing this. Yeah, we got have fun with it sure
back to the book
intellectual trip now
he's talking about intellectual trip intellectual training involves both the acquisition of knowledge and the cultivation of mental power and
Whereas one cannot discuss these entirely as entirely separate things is nevertheless true that people with a great deal of knowledge
Do not necessarily
Have exceptional powers of reasoning or judgment?
That's important
Just because you went to some
Course doesn't mean that you know
Doesn't mean you have good judgment so you can have people that are well read well educated, but they don't have any common sense
That's that's what that sounds like this thing here the cultivation of these powers is not in itself
entail becoming knowledgeable
So in fact these two things can be looked at separately
So there's big difference between you know having information and having I guess we'd say wisdom was he call it
Reasoning and judgment mmm. I'd call reasoning and judgment combined together. I call that wisdom and
Now he talks about moral education
Back to the book in one respect moral education must be carried out from the aspect of knowledge that is to say it is necessary
To know intellectually what is good and what evil?
There's also necessary to develop the intelligence to distinguish right from wrong in various complex situations
Thus it is necessary to teach the ability to determine good from bad to discriminate?
What is right from what is wrong? This is something that I think we're getting away from
Like hey, you know what that's actually wrong like the whole idea
you've you've here people, and I think it's I think they wrap this around a political conversation or a political viewpoint of
There's some people that say like no evil actually exists
Mm-hm and some people just say well
No
people are different and people are raised differently and all that I'm one of the people that like I believe evil exists and and I
Think you can teach, and you have to teach people how to tell the difference between right and wrong
There's some things that are wrong. Yeah. There's some things in the world that are wrong. Yeah, and you shouldn't do them
Strangely, I was talking to Jay pretty in-depth about that idea mmm-hmm
place to a bunch of things where
Even saying okay things are right and things are wrong. That's that's like one way of you know
What the okay, so these people that that say well people are different. There's no real absolute right or wrong the thing is they're
They have a point with that
but here's the thing they're not talking about the same thing you're talking about like do we have a societal standard so and
See it got super complex so obvious it's not the time, but think about this. Let's say a fat person mhm
They're fat everyone can see that they're fat, they know they're fat kind of thing right and
Some people would say it's wrong to indicator to point out that that person is fat in front of people
Even though the fact is that they are okay?
Is it right or wrong to point that out?
It's rude. It's rude exactly alright so ant so is it right to be rude
You was it right or wrong so little scenario dependent things right person situation alright
So the point is yeah the point is there's a societal standard, yeah
And usually it's established just like beat like beating your kids in certain societies is right in certain societies is wrong so
Sure the more extreme the the behavior the easier it is to concern okay. That's all that I think there's a there's a line
Yeah that I think is and it can call yeah, and it goes all the way down
to like almost like a human a like understanding of
Heat like basic human needs in sam harris hill so he talks about um
Suffering like suffering and well-being. That's the two things if something promotes or
Advocates suffering for like no reason way, and he goes into it then that's how you can discern good and evil
Okay, so but at the end of the day it goes down to a standard like a specific standard, yeah
Yeah, but what I'm I guess you're saying the same thing. I'm saying. Yeah, which is like you need to teach people and
And explain what the value system is to two people?
Back to the book in another sense moral education must be carried out from the aspect of the emotions
Even if you can distinguish right from wrong
Intellectually if you are not trained emotionally to like what is good and dislike
What is evil your ability to do good and reject evil will be lacking?
So if morals are not cultivated both
intellectually and emotionally
Good results cannot be achieved
This is big stuff yeah, this is heavy stuff
Back to look furthermore even if you do try
To do good and reject evil if your willpower is weak the opposite result will often occur there for
training of the will must also
Be an element of moral education a weak
Willpower can result in the inability to do what you know is right or the inability to prevent?
Doing what you know is wrong loom
This is the very important stuff a
Weak willpower will you allow bad things to happen you choosing the short-term payoff over thee
Another good example
Back to the book it is also
Important not to look the over not to overlook the element of habit
Even if you intend to do good if you have not developed the habit of doing so your best
intentions will easily be corrupted and
Even the best intentions of rejecting evil can fail if you have not developed the habit of doing so
For that reason you must endeavor to cultivate good habits love. What is good and reject
What is evil on a daily basis? You know what this supports this supports
That whole you know when when I talk about the fact that like if you make good decisions like if you wake up early that
Goes, that's a habit and that helps you that strengthens your ability to reject weakness
whereas if you sleep in your lazy you hit the snooze button your
Double-fist and donuts into your mouth guess what you're gonna be weak, then I'll tell you something else
And I've been talking about this or I've been thinking about this. I've been talking a little, but I've been thinking about this
The way the way that you live every little thing that you do like those actions that you take on a daily basis
That's who you are
And if you don't train correctly if you don't live correctly when the moment of truth comes you won't be able to execute correctly
Yeah
The way you it's like no it's a classic the way you train you
The wave train is that how you fight, right if you don't train hard you're not gonna fight hard
Yeah, if you push yourself mentally when the time comes you'll be able to push yourself
You'll be able to push yourself mentally if you're weak in training. You'll be weakened war
That's the way it is yeah those very
well-put sir we're
Talking last night like I said
And that's what we were talking about - that's what I brought up cuz he was really excited about learning all these new things about
Calculus and all this stuff right cuz he's into AI are efficient machine learning and whatnot so I was like okay
You know you're really excited about learning this stuff, which is good
By the way, and we're just I was I wasn't necessarily talking about him, but I'm it
But just used him as the example so he I was like okay
So what is what is it like you're?
So are you applying this to like your work now or your life or whatever, or you just fired up about learning, so it's like
You can learn about
Everything in the whole wide universe
Right, but if you don't put it into action whenever it's like your habits like what you do that meek
That's who you are you have like let's say. You're you're you I don't know well
Actually, I think you're saying something different. I know what you're saying what you're saying is absolutely true, too
I'm saying little
I'm saying little the little things matters what I'm saying the way you live is the way you live is what I'm saying
Yeah, yeah, okay. Yeah what you're saying. It is also important like hey. You got this. What are you gonna do with it? Yeah?
Yeah, that's what you're saying and that also is important like okay. Will you work for this, but now?
What are you gonna do with it? You got this gift? What are you gonna do with this gift?
You've got this talent when you can do this town. You got this education
What do you do with this education those are all so important, yeah?
And what I'm saying is if you don't develop the habit of
Putting things into place and being efficient and working hard you can take those gifts those talents in that education you can piss it away
You know that's what I'm saying. Yeah, if you're used to taking the easy road you get that knowledge
You don't do anything with it. Yeah, so live your life with intent
That's what I'm saying every day every little decision you make matters it matters
Matters what you do
Expanding this out a little bit back to the book if each member of a group helps others and acts
Selflessly the group can be harmonious and act as one accordingly the group can make the best use of its energy
Just like an individual this principle remains true even in the case of a complex society with a population of millions
You help each other out
This is very this is what this is you know this is like a SEAL team, right?
This is like a seal platoon you help each other you support each other. That's what makes you good
That's what makes you good
Here's another one. Let's say someone draws a sword on you. This is getting back into training
Let's say someone draws a sword on you any
Hesitations in your actions will result in you being injured or killed
You must react automatically?
Instinctively just as when you blink impulsively when a fly approaches your eye
You must dodge your attacker an instant in order to do this. You must pratik practice
This as physical education and train on a regular basis to build up your body while also undergoing martial arts training
So I like this idea of a fly getting your eye right the fly doesn't hit your eye you blink
That's what happens you have the instinct and what's cool
I see this with extreme ownership when people first hear about the concept like it's foreign to them a
Utah you've talked about this how once you started thinking about it?
You'd see like any excuse that someone makes you're like. Oh, man this guy's not taking ownership
That's just an excuse and then you see it in yourself and when that becomes your instinct because you're living that way well
Then it's very easy to spot. It's also easier to maintain yeah
That's why the little things matter
That go yes, sir
Back to the book judo began with the study of martial arts and then it gradually became clear that it could be applied to physical
education intellectual training moral education social engagement management and people's everyday lives
Some people believe that judo means simply practicing at the dojo
This is applying the principle of Judo at the dojo
when practicing
defense against attack and
Though it certainly is one aspect of judo is only a small part of it with judo in every endeavor you must imagine the best
goal
And use your mental and physical energy the most effective manner in order to accomplish that goal
For that reason judo is not merely a martial art, but rather the basic principle of human behavior
It is wrong to assume judo ends in the dojo
so
He's saying apply this everywhere. I'm saying you should do that you can do it with jiu-jitsu
Now we're going back into this sere do Co Zhen you certain teachings
Have a long tradition so most people accept them, but when people do not understand why they are taught a certain way
Conflicts conflicts can sometimes arrive arise to give example virtually. No one doubts that diligence is a good thing
right no one doubts that diligence is a good thing if
Diligence is always a good thing it falls that there can be no situation in which being diligent is bad
But if you are diligent in an irresponsible
Manner you will spend a great deal of effort on something that is not very useful and expend the energy required to do something good
wastefully
You must carefully choose something for which diligence is suited
Even when we do what we believe to be best over doing something can be harmful
When students stay up late reading a book because their teachers parents or society has deemed it best that they should read it
This is certainly diligence, but is also detrimental to their health to read for so long
Conversely you cannot do things half-heartedly or randomly so
You got to stay balanced
Let us turn to the into an annoying yet pervasive habit o people all too often display complaining
What is the point of complaining it is certainly no fun for those who have to listen to the complaints the?
Energy used to make an unpleasant complaints can certainly not be considered
Serio kou Zhen yo
Rather all the energy used to complain or
Grumble should be expended more usefully this means ridding oneself of unpleasant feelings and refraining from
harboring ill-will towards others the this end
In the end this will result in putting one's energy to the best use not only for oneself
But also for the betterment of society this principle should be applied everyday at all times
Don't waste your energy on stuff that doesn't matter
Back to the book if people are always aware of their current situation
And set a standard for their future based on doing what will benefit themselves in society and continually regulate their behavior
They can be satisfied with their lives at all times
When you try to do this you'll find that your future prospects are always bright that is because you're doing what is best
How how common sense is this right and it's so common sense, but how many people do you know that follow this path?
That's the question
yeah, that goes back to
How you say that idea of being detached when you detached, it's common sense yeah, but when you're in the game
It's not common sense because of how you just like how that said how you feel?
Like you know like even complaining for example like you could ask
I don't say literally everyone, but you could ask everyone and be like hey
Complaining is that useful is that good to do is that fine - you know just complain, right?
Yes
Or no
Everyone's oh no no no no what does everyone complain that cuz when you're in the game complaining if you could I feel better whenever
You picked up on it very well because it's as if people are always aware of their current situation
meaning, they need to be detached and
Then set a standard for the future based on doing things that just think it's the same thing
Sleep is it smart to do things that will benefit themselves and society
Continually continue regulate your behavior so that you're satisfied with your life, and although of course that makes sense sure why don't we do it?
We get off the path we get on the slippery slope we start losing our awareness of our what is it current state?
Well, how do I put it in the current situation for institution yet understand it? Yeah?
This is interesting through judo
we are teaching a principle that can work together with the highest principles of Buddhism and Christianity and the
exhaustive studies of philosophers
One where like other great philosophies and religious can be put into action
This principle of Judo offers a basic principle that can provide a sound answer for every situation in every question the easiest way to master
This basic principle is to practice the Wazza of judo and to embark on the dough the way
That is because through practice that
Incorporates both a martial art and physical education one can learn a method for making the most effective use of one's mental and physical energy
then one naturally learns how to apply this method to every aspect of human affairs I
Believe that this basic principle is the most appropriate method for resolving various moral issues
Then he puts a lot of weight on the judo a lot of weight on the judo noodle is life
Yeah with regard to our daily activities and social interaction the teaching of Ciriaco, zen, yo means
Bringing about maximum results through the use of every sort of energy for this reason
human faults like anger for example
violate this principle
Becoming angry consumes mental energy, how does anger benefit you or anyone else the?
Result of anger are invariably a depletion of mental energy and being looked down on or disliked by others
by following the principle of Serio guzheng yo
People will not be able to get angry being
Disappointed or troubled by failures or setbacks or harboring grievances are also ways in which mental energy is consumed
Arguments fights all of these are violations of Serio cuisine yo
Those who practice judo must take great care to follow this teaching no matter what the situation
There is only one path that people must follow in every case the only course is to consider
What is the right thing to do and proceed in that direction?
What is the right thing to do and do that you know
What is the right thing to do and do that that's what you should do regardless of how you feel yes? I
Have coined a phrase that I regularly say to people there is only one path in life
conducting yourself in accordance with this principle on a daily basis is vitally important though human beings may reach the
pinnacle of success
there is only one path down which to proceed that is to say because
complacency gives rise to the cause of failure
You must always consider things carefully until you find the appropriate course of action and proceed that way even when you fail
There's only one path down which to proceed
Even if once you fail and lose heart if you regain your courage and find your way along the highest path
The highest path circumstances will gradually improve. That's like Jordan Peterson talking right hey, you know like
Get on do the right thing
Pick a little thing and start proving that then clean your room
Because they find their own paths those who practice judo and who follow the principle of serial cuisine you
Always, have a calm spirit
enjoy life
And are enterprising the most advanced mental life can only be achieved
when people thoroughly absorb this principle
City oku Zen u
Maximum efficiency what are you doing that is taking away your energy? What are you wasting your energy on?
Back to the book a true a person's true value is determined by how much he or she contributes to society during his or her
life
And because these very contributions enable those who strive to protect themselves to achieve this
The purpose of Judo is to perfect yourself so that you can contribute to society
This applies to ordinary people as well again
This is very very similar to what Jordan Peterson talks about
Like you you need to if you if you fix your world. Well. Do you impact me everyone's world around you mm-hmm?
This applies to ordinary people as well
But in particular those who specialized in judo must be expected to act in a way consistent with the purposes of Judo
When you practice judo you must try to perfect yourself and contribute to society through this practice
And you must emphasize the importance of this during your teachings to others
Something that seems good because it is near at hand
May be useless in the future whereas in some cases a bit of patience is highly effective in furthering your law in the future
right delayed gratification
The basis of happiness in life
is found not in the pursuit of material gains or temporary pleasure and
True kindness towards one's friends means giving them serious advice when needed
selflessly without fear of offending them
Now that one's interesting because I deal with this one a lot right I deal this with a lot because
You got your your subordinate. That's not doing what they're supposed to do, and I just was having this conversation with a
Group I was working with and they were real big on the word transparency of life
and I talked about it on the podcast and and
If
Here's the question like I'm gonna be transparent with you like like hey echo
Your videos you you know they're not good right now
Like your videos aren't good
You need to tighten up your videos like does that make does that improve our relationship?
does that make you want to do a good job for me does that make you want to like get out there and
Really, crush it mmm. No not at all so you know
I'm being transparent doesn't help our situation doesn't help what we're trying to do
no, it doesn't so I need to figure out a way to tell you something and
Normally the best way to do that and here's a big hint for everyone. That's out there if you want to give someone critique
That they know that you know they need
One of the best ways to give them critique is to take ownership of it take ownership of the problem
so I say echo hey I
Feel like I'm not really giving you good guidance on on the videos and the way they're coming out
Mm-hmm I want to sit down and talk to you and actually go through like what what the impact that we're trying to have
I want to have and I mean I know you're working hard, but I feel like I'm not giving you good enough guidance
I want to sit down with you and try and see if I can be more clear
mm-hmm, right
Does that offend you no?
Well, I know you're doing now, but yeah, yeah
Yeah, yeah, so you take if you take ownership of the problem
And then you talk about the problem with the person it puts
it doesn't it makes it makes them not have a defensive posture, which is what you
Which is what you want you want don't want them to have a defensive posture
Mmm. I actually want to have them have an open mind and be able to listen what I say
They won't listen if you're pointing the finger at him. Yeah. They won't listen as well
They might listen for a little while yeah, but it won't be a lasting they may be years later
Maybe or something like yeah won't help the relationship. We know that I'm not sure
You must remember that the purpose of expending a great deal of effort to build a strong body is to enable you to
Undertake jobs that you might otherwise be unable to endure so what he's talking about there. He's dog mouth
He basically goes on this whole thing about like being big and buff sure
He's not pro in that down for that's not down for the calls like echo Charles
He would look at you and think you're wasting too much time on your on your bicep curls. Yeah
Might be right
Yeah, so that's what he's saying is that he's but he's all about the functional strength you want to be strong so you can do
Jobs that you might not be able to endure if you didn't work hard didn't work out hard. Hey
That's a balancing act too. I know you're gonna defend the biceps. I mean of the curls, but
But you know how like they say it's even like like kind of like
because about example, but he said
You wanna save your energy essentially for jobs that are like important rights? No
No, he says the reason that you're trying to get strong isn't so you can look big and buff
It's so that you can do jobs
You can endure jobs that you wouldn't bail - okay gotcha so that that should be the focus of your training
Functional strength functions, what these are he's down with the functional strength
This guy need to super funny, bro science. I think I told this deep bro. It's life for someone
So funny, and he's talking about functional strength. He said so you know it's jokes or whatever anything?
Yeah, so good luck. You can compare your functional strength with my actual strength
But in his mind actual strength so it's like how much you can bitch, and yeah, you know how it is
Well yeah, that's so not every time
I hear like when a guy's starts like heavily advocating functional strength over like uh some some
Weightlifter guy or whatever. I think about that that's even though. I'm sure this book came out a lot a lot
You know earlier than bro science life
Jack
Alright back to the book some who practiced judo become overconfident of their health and inevitably fail to look after themselves
We must not be careless about where we live our clothing or our hygiene
We should pay great attention to what we eat and drink there was a time when people did not deem it a problem to eat
And drink to excess, but rather we're proud of a prolific a proud of being a prolific eater or a heavy drinker
That way of thinking still persists
And is obviously detrimental to health if you do not take care in regard to matters of health there is no benefit in practicing judo
Those who practice judo must not only keep this in mind, but must also consider it their duty to remind others
That's bolded their their duty to remind that was a star next to that
This guy did again. This guy is like super orderly yeah, and he's
You know just gonna tighten people up. You know he's out there going don't eat that doughnut. Yeah
But to the nth degree
Yeah, that's your duty come on, bro. Yeah, you know it's my duty. I'm gonna. Go you know
I'm gonna go to the mall and buy the food court. You know what's funny is. This is the only thing in the whole book
That he says like Judah won't help like if you if you're not healthy do does not even train stop train
He has a thing yeah. He doesn't like that
Yeah
he's what's that called a
pic I hang up yeah, that's
Yeah, that's the thing yeah
Because judo derives from the martial arts of the past it must perpetuate the spirit of other martial arts
loyalty faith honour and various other virtues were emphasized in the martial arts of the past
but I keenly feel their importance even today the deterioration of
Society's morals today is primarily the result of a failure to emphasize these virtues
So I believe that those who practice judo in particular must apply themselves to these matters and restore
today's neglected public morals
He's got another little hang-up, I wasn't ready to hang up
He's but I mean obviously I'm pointing this out because we could clearly look at society today and be like err
Well guess what we were on a slippery slope. Yeah. Yeah, you can tell you feel strongly about that all right there
Who me or heal him oh, yeah?
Yeah, yeah, what about me? Yeah, just yeah, the look on your face indicated that for sure
Yeah, you know that's a whole nother thing. It's
It's weird cuz you go around different pockets of the world in different pockets of the country and you see various
various positions on the slippery slope some people hanging on yeah, but some people are not and they're just slipping and
We gotta be careful. Yeah, and you get and obviously that's a whole nother topic
but the
You know and you have so many huge major major forces kind of working against it
You know pushing us to down the slippery slope like marketing right you know like marketing most
Marketing is to appeal to your most like immediate wants
Double whatever you know it's the girl that's showing the delicious burgers like yeah, and guess what doesn't even cost that much mmm
You know so gratification for cheap yeah, man, so you can get it in the sex throne on top of that
Yeah, make you feel good
You know what you know and that's everything so you know again
If you're not what is it conscious of your situation or whatever you might know sleep?
like is
Like I think people lose concentration, that's because most people
In my opinion most people are like they kind of know you know we like we go back to the theory of right and wrong
What's right? I think most people are pretty good with it like most people feel pretty like that. They know what's behave like it
Oh, that's wrong right and they know that hey, you know what that's a good thing to do right. I think most people kind of
Like broadly kind of kind of a would agree with those things
Yes
The problem is and so that's why I think we don't emphasize as much because we think you know what?
Most people pretty much agree with me like it's like the center
People of the country right now like and the extreme right now the extreme left. No, okay. Where are you at?
It's like okay. Well those people that are in the middle. It's like yeah
We we kind of figure like okay pretty much, and so what happens is once
We don't talk about it as much well, then the people that are on the fringes mentally
They end up without a compass right they just don't even know what's right
And what's wrong anymore because people aren't talking about as much because it doesn't seem like we need to mmm
I think we might need to
Yeah
Yeah, and why it's right, then it comes down to your approach and like all this stuff
Cuz you know when you have opposing views. It's like if you don't do it with the right approach you
Just it becomes more about the fight more so than for sure you know the kind so yeah
I think you're right about that. I think our and are you talking about?
People most people know right and wrong because there's a difference between like just like how
You were saying where?
People know right and wrong, but they don't always do what's right kind of thing probably so is that what you're talking about like
Well no no I'm saying I'm saying
If you don't teach a kid like hey when you see someone that needs help you go help them Yeah, right?
Like little old lady crossing the street, right?
Right that seems obvious a little old lady cross the street. She's got a grocery bag
You you go okay? Hey can I help you with that grocery bag?
And you know help you put it in your car
Maybe for you you get a little pump while you're at it with that groceries. Yeah, hope she has a bunch
Yeah, so like that's that seems like a real common-sense thing to do and that's like the most
Basic example I can think of off the top of my head like okay, so that that would be a good thing to Train
A kid to do hey if you see someone that needs some help you give them some help
Yeah, especially an elderly person that's having some trouble. That's what you do
Yeah, seems real obvious, but what I'm saying it, and and I think even I think most people
Most kids would be like oh yeah. They'd see that and they would tend to go ok. I'll help out
But because most people would tend to do that we think we don't need to teach him good
And that's where we're losing it like because the people on the fringes. They're not helping that person. There's someone on the fringe
That's gonna like oh they drop their bag move steal it from them yeah, right so that's where we end up with a problem. Yeah
Yeah, sure, and that's why these things probably need to come up as part of a conversation
a tional or
Universal conversations to be had like okay. What is right and wrong
Who's given those guidance is now yeah?
Where are they coming from evil are people three people aren't reading the Bible anymore to look for their guidance
They're not following Buddhism to get their guidance from right. They're just they're just kind of going around
Yeah, so where's that coming from yeah, that's true. They're going like going around. They're seen like what okay?
They're looking around me like okay. What are we doing? How are we doing?
This is right is this wrong now, and you do it
And what are they looking at to get to measure to to establish that from you know what they're looking at Instagram?
Yeah, uh whatever's are on the mat. Whatever's around but instagrams around me you to man around them
Yeah, that's what's around them, and they're looking at it going okay. Well this is
You know that seems so weird all right cool. That's what we're doing. Yeah. Yeah, okay to sucker-punch this
You know this this old, dude
Yeah, yeah, you know I you know and I feel a little uncomfortable on it, but you know what it seems normal
Yeah, people are doing it fun. Yeah guys are laughing
I got a lot of views got a lot of yes, maybe that's what's cool. Yeah
that's what we need to watch out for yeah, and obviously I know that's an extreme case but
Really that that that's true
We're especially okay in these extreme cases will happen by the way if you don't have any other presence of influencer. You know how like
Kind of saying this it thought it made sense where
Kid your kids or whatever they're gonna learn how to behave
whether they learn it from you or
Your neighbor or TV or the guy at the club or the guy at the park?
Whatever that part is up to you like if you don't want to be there
They're gonna learn it from somebody else kind of thing so
That idea where okay? What are we you know? This is a society like okay? What are we doing now?
How are we doing this? What's right?
What's wrong? Is this wrong now? Whatever then we're gonna get that does it guy you said like we're looking around
We're trying to see what up you know
And if there's no specific thing saying or court not quote necessarily a course yeah, even though of course would be cool
if there's nothing
Present there to demonstrate it then they're gonna be like all right. Well. What is here to demonstrate it and what I'm saying is
We've gotten away from things that in the past would have guided us at least someone
And you'd had this sort of
Sort of fundamental Universal understanding of like thou shalt not kill right sure well
Okay, that that. That's a biblical thing and well you know maybe when a kid is
15 years old and he's feeling angry about something and
He's thinking you know what I play a video game all day where I shoot like people in this video game and that makes me
Feel better well, maybe make me feel better to go out and do that in a school
Yeah, right, that's that's that's what happens
Yeah, so if we don't have if we don't lay out these things for people even though most people don't need them
There's some people that need them
That's my point
Is that we've gotten to a point where we think you know what pretty much everyone kind of gets it
And if everyone kind of gets it, I don't need to emphasize that much yeah, and so I'm not gonna emphasize it
Yeah, well there's some people that need it
Yeah, and even if you don't quote-unquote need it. It's kind of like exercising. You know a great shape
I don't got exercise wool yet. You kind of do. You know yeah, it's interesting times
Yeah
This is interesting speaking of interesting
instructive talks on morals
Presented in the classroom often become abstract or involve stories of people from the distant past
So they're not likely to inspire the listener
But moral lessons that can be acquired through judo's randori are based on facts and are much more likely to make an impression
and it can be said that the habit of observation the ability to
Make decisions quickly and the ability to remain calm and resolute that are cultivated through fighting are also
valuable outcomes of the practice of Judo these abilities
However will not be developed merely by doing kata and randori training without any thought
These abilities will naturally develop when one takes care and fought in practicing them on a daily basis
So this is this is something very interesting think about so I thought that was great like hey you learned about something
You know you read the Bible. You know it's like ah that doesn't really make sense to me
It's some guy that lived thousands of years ago and well
I don't really get that I
Don't really get why I should be humble because it says you should be humble well get on the mat
Now you get humbled and you feel you get humbled right so there's that's that's like the perfect
Example of how hey what you learn on the mat?
Is is truly understood, but if you're don't get no
and if no if you don't think about the fact that hey that reflects life - by the way that
Reflects life by the way if no one makes that connection for you. That's problematic and I mean clearly
Jiu-jitsu
This is a big difference between jiu-jitsu and judo if we talked about what the competitions are like you talk about how you get disqualified
Jiu-jitsu you have people and jiu-jitsu that have bad attitudes, right?
But they don't they don't apply what they learn in jiu-jitsu so one of the things that
You know you know my attitude always is with jiu-jitsu is like
if I get if I beat someone in jiu-jitsu
If you're if you
Understand jiu-jitsu if you beat someone in jiu-jitsu you realize that doesn't make you a better
person than the person that you beat what it means is you've trained more than them that's what it means or
It means you caught him that time means you got lucky with a move it means they made a mistake and you had trained enough
To be able to capitalize on it
It doesn't mean you're a better human being than they are
and
There there are people in jiu-jitsu that think oh I am a better
Human being than that person is because I him out it's like actually no not true at all
Yeah, so if you're not connecting these bigger broader lessons and connecting jiu-jitsu
Life
Then what you have is just just this isolated sport, which diverges which is a it's not even a sport
It's an it's an isolated
Might makes right attitude on the mat, which is not a good thing yeah
It's not a good thing at all jiu-jitsu should be making you humble because you should recognize like oh, yeah well
I've been training longer than this guy and that's why I can beat them and
One day if they keep training more than me
They'll be able to beat me so hopefully I'll keep training and we'll have a relationship
And we'll be able to support each other and that's the attitude yeah, so I think that's one of the things where
You know you've got in my mind. You've got judo on one side, which is you know really strict and
controlled and and
less
Evolutionary because it doesn't evolve as much and you have jiu-jitsu on the other hand which is wildly
Evolutionary it's incredibly creative like there's a there's less creativity in judo. There's way more creativity in jiu-jitsu and I
think in the middle
especially on the attitude part is where
Jiu-jitsu now is like you need like you go to jiu-jitsu competition like little kids that are they have their bad sports right their bad
Sports teams they did not learn sportsmanship hmm
And that's an important thing because what a sportsmanship mean sportsmanship doesn't just mean like you're a good sport on the mat
No, it means that in life. You can handle getting beaten and you're gonna get back up and you're gonna. Have a good attitude
that's what sportsmanship is that's why you're trying to teach that to your kids Yeah, right and
There's a million little things like that in jiu-jitsu that you learned like just the hard training. Well you you know what in jiu-jitsu
Sometimes you work hard and you still get beat yeah, that's the way life is yes sir
That's the way life is you work hard you give it everything you got you still gonna get beat
well guess what do you learn from that you learn about life from that yeah, the creativity part if
You're stuck in a box on something and and he talked about that earlier like oh, yeah when he's talking about there's only one path
Again, I talked about him as being a very
I won't see not creative, but he's got an orderly brain, right
I never look at something that there's one path yeah like and by the way if I fail in business
He's like hey. There's only one path. No if I fail in business. I'm actually gonna look and see like well
Okay, what other path could I take now? He's talking about the path like like I'm not saying hell
No the hell with discipline
And I'm gonna do whatever I want so he's saying stay on that path and that makes sense
But there is a certain lack of creativity there like okay. Well if I make a mistake
I'm to assess, and I'm gonna see what I can do differently again
I'm not arguing that that's that he was saying. No don't ever try anything else but
That is an important piece that you learned from jiu-jitsu like oh if I can't pass the guard
This person's guard this particular way
I need to take a different approach you learned that from jiu-jitsu and you can apply it to life so all these lessons
That if you don't pay attention to what you're learning in jiu-jitsu
And you don't reflect on it and put it back on your life
Well, then all you're learning is how to fight people and beat them up
Well, then jiu-jitsu is not doing what it should it's not doing what it could be doing for you
Yeah, look you need to be careful that yeah
I think his thing his one path is is it's this really broad in general kind of Dura. It's more of a direction
Yeah, it is. It is. That's a bad example for me to use
But at the same time I want to make sure people aren't like well. You know I'm gonna stay on the path
I'm gonna stay the course. I'm gonna stay the course. You know what we failed that time, but it's okay
I'm gonna stay the course. I'm gonna keep going no no no assess see what you can do differently
All right
Effective use of mental and physical energy again. He's he's talking about this
Sukira Zen yo an integral which is integral to the teachings of Judo competition can be applied to many aspects of life those who practice
Judo must measure their behavior by this principle on a daily basis and make corrections when appropriate if you actually apply this standard to every
Aspect of your life from food clothing and shelter to your work and relationships
You'll find that you often have to correct your own mistakes those
Who do this will make progress day-by-day in advance in life those who fail to?
Do so will never progress and in many cases
will regress
So keep an eye on those little things
With regard to memory in the early stages of practices of Judo
You must do what you have been taught in order to do this. You must remember things as well as practice progresses
You must you must remember not only what you have been taught
But also what you have observed so there are many situations in which memory is vital you will develop that ability
Naturally to come up with ways to remember things
He's talking about some of the benefits of learning judo
So one of those you learn to remember things next we come to the area of imagination
This is not particularly necessary during the early stages of the practice of Judo
But becomes quite necessary later you may experience experiment with various outcomes carefully anticipating
How your opponent will react but if there is a limit to the ideas?
You can come up with and if the range is narrow. No good ideas will come to you no matter how much time passes on
The other hand if you come up with a variety of ideas one after another and if your thoughts
Extend to things quite different from your original idea
you can come up with a perfect solution among those ideas so he talks about creativity and
This is interesting next come loose language
This is very important to the practice of Judo the reason is it is
The reason is that in randori as well as in kata if you try and explain a particular
Method in words unless you explain it exceptionally logically and clearly your listener will not understand what you mean
There are some things that can be demonstrated in detail using kata while others
Do not lend themselves to this method in some cases you must explain things in writing or verbally when teaching whether you
Demonstrate things through kata only or by giving a verbal explanation while demonstrating the kata makes a big difference to the listener
This is a truism when you ask something when you ask someone about something you do not understand or
Discuss something in depth it is highly beneficial if you can talk about it clearly
Thus it is so in the practice of Judo take care take care to discuss things?
logically and clearly so even he talks about the importance of being able to express yourself and
Having good command of the language hmm it applies to judo is that reaching maybe a little bit
But we'll give it to him. I'm gonna give it to him
Do you know yeah the way I see it is like you know that what is the laws of combat simple?
Oh, yeah, that's that's what
Sighs yeah for sure yeah, you're right good. Call I
like it
Next I would like to discuss the need for
broad-mindedness
broad-mindedness means open to new ideas as well as the ability to organize various kinds of ideas at the same time without
mixing them up
The reason this is important to the practice of Judo is that when there is no broad-mindedness
People often become overly confident in their own beliefs such that if there are new ideas that are superior
Not only do they not accept these new ideas
But in doing so they failed to determine their value and whether they are good or bad
This is something you see all the time with people with ego a closed mind
they don't listen anybody else they don't come up with any new ideas, it's
Horrible so keep an open mind
My way or the highway yeah, or is that a different thing? You don't want none of that my name is aiwei. Yeah
This is speaking of simple the theory of Judo fighting includes some quite complicated
Ideas when we consider the relationship between the body and the four limbs their positions how to use them how to handle the mental
Aspects one theory gets mixed up with many others, so it becomes difficult to reach an overall conclusion even if we link
these complicated theories to look at them separately the ability to unify them in the end must be the second requirement for
broad-mindedness
You can't be able to connect things you gotta be able to simplify things
This is interesting
there is a teaching in judo competition that says one must look at the relationship between oneself and others and
one's surroundings
So you have to orient is is the zoo de Loup yeah?
This is a loop so you have to you have to orient yourself to
What's happening? You have to look around and see what's going on?
Another one in judo fighting there is a teaching
Sake ohtori which means anticipate simply put this means using your Wazza on your opponent before
He can use his walls on you boom be aggressive default aggressive
Don't wait for the enemy to do something mm-hmm you do it first
There is another teaching in judo fighting do Kiril donk oh and
this translates to
decisive action after careful consideration
Dookie arrow means carefully considering the situation before attempting to use a wasa
Donk Oh means acting without delay once you have made a decision
When this teaching is applied to the path people take in life it can indeed be relevant in many situations. This is a good one
What youyou consider what you're gonna do but then once you make a decision you go you go full speed
You go full speed you always reassess you always keep your mind open even when I'm like I made a decision like hey
Or you know what we've debated this enough. Let's go even when I say that and I mean it
I'm still just making sure I always make sure yeah, yeah
And then I run to my death it seems like he's more talking about like don't don't don't don't make a decision
Go and then hesitate the whole time. That's definitely true and also don't sit there and wait to make a decision
You know make a decision, but this is what's interesting?
Here's here's a conch back to the book a further teaching which seems to be somewhat
Contradictory to donk o is known as toe tomaru
Kokoro o Scheider and that translates know when to stop
This means that when you venture to use a Wazza up to a certain point, but when you reach that point
You must stop
again this rule has
Universal applicability to many aspects of life as well, so there you go
You got those two opposing forces one is like go and the other ones like know when to stop
So those are let's just say very important
One of the most important concepts and judo fighting says if you win do not boast of your victory if you lose
Do not be discouraged when it is safe. Do not be careless when it is dangerous
Do not fear simply continue down the path ahead
Right those are normal face. Yeah normal face yes affirmative
When encountering social pressures such as those such as those we experienced today even an
incredibly strong willed person can lose spirit and experience great adversity
This is when we must this is when he must show true character at times like these the ability to overcome
Difficulties endure and be patient preserved ones honor and maintain a spirit of integrity are truly valuable above all else
In order to do this first you must develop good daily habits
these good habits include simplicity and
Moderation and while thinking of yourself always keep other people and society as a whole in mind as well
You must not trouble others for your own convenience, and if you can you must try to benefit others while benefiting yourself
In other words you must perfect yourself and contribute to society, which is the ultimate purpose of the study of Judo?
Then judo is a lot bigger than you thought it was it is. Yes, sir. He's trying to take it to the distance
No way those who want to do something to benefit society must first make sure they can easily take care of their own business
Yeah clean your room. Yeah as Jordan he says
Take care of your own business
You know then you can worry about the rest of society look two oxygen masks you put it on yourself first
Then you put it on your coz if you're suffocating how you gonna help your kid you're not you can't here
We get a little controversy professional wrestlers and boxers are generally people of low character
I don't know if they can sit on oh definitely don't sign on with that and no matter how superior their skills they're mostly looked
down on by society
I guess we'd have to do some research as to what the boxers and wrestlers were like back in his time in Japan
some Kodokan members have gained popularity
popularity performing on tour with them
But I don't believe this behavior is - is in accord with the aim of Judo true judo practitioners must not be performers
Hmm, so that's there you go right that explains a lot. Yeah sure he won't like McGregor
No, no, no, I'm like down the pond for sure McGregor don't care. No
All right
And this is this is again
I I had to call these things out because obviously I don't agree with
ball wrestlers and boxers being people of low character in fact
I believe the opposite of that
But here's a good one in the future
When asked to compete against wrestlers or boxers the competitors must decide whether the judo?
Practitioners will compete under the rules of boxing arrest wrestling or whether the opponent will compete under the rules of Judo
however those contests must never be commercialized
They must be merely trials between volunteers for the purpose of research if for some reason
showman
Should get involved people get charged admission
And it becomes a spectator sport you must recognize that this is in complete violation of the spirit of Kodokan judo
Hmm, so what about Olympic judo, then that's that's a violation
Yeah, I mean there's a lot of things you'd call, but actually you know judo gene LeBell
Yeah, he fought he fought against the boxer Milo Savage in
and
I think it was Denver
I forget what it was, but yeah
That was like that's kind of noted as sort of the beginning of like whatever popular MMA
right boxer versus judoka
and judo gene LeBell is a
American
Icon he's an icon of grappling if you don't know judo gene LeBell is look him up. He's awesome
And he actually so he did this back in the day back in 1963
What do you think the outcome was boxer versus judo yeah in a fight fight?
No, they fought they fought they fought like in an MMA fight
I mean it was it was an it was you fight each other go
Let's gene the bill then yeah, that's Ching the bell all day right yeah takedown rear naked choke. That's what he got yeah
That's what he got. That's how it went
so
Yeah
that's
You know it's just interesting how completely commercialized
Yeah, this is and it's also interesting that again closed mindedness, or I don't know if you call it closed mindedness
But he has a very orderly brain yeah, and he was like look. It's either gonna be
Those rules or these rules. He didn't think to himself like hey, you know what what if you just mix it up
And you do it all together. Yeah, all rules. Yeah, all rules. Why wouldn't we do that?
Which is interesting because in judo they do cover striking, and you don't hear about it much
But they have those are part of it hmm, so it's interesting that in his mind is like knowing
It's either those rules. Yeah, these rules. Yeah, very rigid yeah, very rigid thinker yeah, that's a good point
Back to the book in everyday randori practice fighting against another person is not the real purpose of the practice of Judo
Because fighting to see who will win is interesting it is done on a daily basis. Yes it is
It goes without saying that becoming able to beat someone is one of the ultimate goals of the practice of randori however
There's clearly a difference between becoming able to beat someone at a future time and becoming obsessed at beating someone now
In order to beat someone now
It is best for those who are strong to use that strength to overcome the other person's strength however with that method if you encode?
Encounter opponent who is much stronger than you, are you will naturally lose
So even if you lose for a while the correct practice of randori is to slip dexterously away from your opponent
Adapt to his strength caused him to lose his balance while stepping back and then take advantage the opportunity to perform a Wazza
if you do this kind of training you will
For a while often be twisted by the arm and held down or push down by your opponent
But if you do not frequently engage in this kind of training you will never learn how to beat a stronger opponent
So this is what we talk about all the time when we talk about
relaxing and trying to relax and
Putting yourself in bad positions, and not using your strengths. That's what we're talking about and again
That applies to life as well that applies to
Not stayin in your comfort zone
Not in continuing to concentrate on what you're good at mmm focus on your weaknesses
That's what that talks about
It's interesting his how he said don't don't
Be focused on beating the other guy
You know it's almost like holier talked about that real briefly right when I first met him where Hughes I got
Like it's not like you're not looking how big the guy is how tough? He is what belty has and all this stuff
It's like you're focusing on on your jiu-jitsu what's lacking what I know and don't know
You know if I'm focusing on the other guy in ya. I'm gonna beat him and all this stuff
That's not what what the jujitsu is yeah, and I'll go ahead and say this like this is
This sounds good
It's but we all I mean at least every single person I trained with like
We're trying to we're trying to wait yeah
That being said now actually I'm gonna go ahead and correct myself like we train we want to win
But like you take way more risks training with our with our training team
Then you would take if you were training with someone else
Yeah, right you take you know you take rescue try new things you put yourself in a bad position
So I'm gonna try this I'm gonna try this arm lock. I'm gonna try this choke even though
I might end up on the bottom, but that's okay. Well. You know what I mean, so I guess that's true
I don't focus completely on just trying to beat the other person
Yeah, so that's that's actually very accurate and I think as you are as you start this game
That's the best attitude to have is like hey you
Got to relax. I was talking to a buddy mind
That's just starting jiu-jitsu out and he's like my age, and yeah, he's like man. I'm trying to relax Parker
Tried to relax harder and actually what I do I send him a text
I was like it's like rock climb have you ever done a rock climbing before yes
So there's technique in rock climbing like there's legit technique obviously
Well, it's not obvious if you've never Rock climbed before there's a massive amount of technique in rock climbing
It's the way you position your fingers the way position your hands the way you use your legs you don't hang the weight on your
Muscles you hang it on your your bones and your ligaments
So you're not getting tired your muscles aren't getting tired out because you're using the technique
If you don't know rock climbing guess what you do you hang on to the freakin rock with all your muscle and just as long
As you can that's exactly what happens in jiu-jitsu when your technique is good. You're just gonna hang on yeah
you know
That he the whole thing about you Justin winning, and he and he used the word obsessed
Yeah in reason when you really look at it, I mean as in the moment yeah, you want to beat the guy like that
That's when you train or someone in jiu-jitsu or especially when you compete in jiu-jitsu. That's actually where the shift kind of curs
he mentioned competition as
Not a spectator sport. This is just for experimental purposes
research research search purposes
Which is essentially just training really for sure it's kind of like kind of how when they started the first UFC that
That was what they were kind of pushing to they're like we're gonna
See how what martial arts style exactly right and but really you know the people the thing that people
Came to see was that for sure, but it was a show who's gonna win, and oh yeah, yeah
And when you really look at it, so you see one two all these things
it was I
Don't want to say rare, but it was almost rare when aside from points Gracie of course
And you know Ken Shamrock and stuff like this. It was really rare to see the style get maintained
It was like these karate guys had their stance and the fight was started as a street fight
Yeah, exactly right so and that was part of the research kind of kind of thing
But you know people were there to see who's gonna kick whose ass
but
It in jiu-jitsu when you're really when you really think about it you
we are kind of maintaining that like we want to see like we're
Researching all the time yeah and useful work
And you're you can you can fall back and forth like sometimes you can get sucked into being obsessed with beating that guy and maybe
If you kind of use it, you know it's like using anger to help you
I don't know get more strength or something just for a moment or whatever I kind of think that's okay
And I think we all kind of do it in one way or another not the anger thing necessarily
But that I'm gonna like me in you for example. I might incorporate a little bit up today, so I'm gonna get Junko today
That's what I'm kind of focused on it for a second. Yeah, yeah for a second to help me get better
Maybe even get me past a mental barrier or something like that and you know you can do it
But the big picture is just what he's talking about
I just want to get better it might do kind of thing and I will say this too. I
Eagerly
Positive to be like yeah
I don't want to lose and and the only way you're not gonna lose is to train all the time
Yeah, so the days that you the days you're like well. You know I don't like yesterday
I I was on a different time zone came back. It was I got back in the day
I had a work to do as soon as I hit the ground I got done with that
I hit a quick workout, and now it's like. Oh, it's guess. What time it is jujitsu time, and I'm like well
You know oh, well you know maybe it's been a long day look at my shoulder kind of hurts right now
So maybe I'll just you know dress
Then I was like no
Go go to train because because what I know is not training
No, it's it's this is not training one day might not make a difference
But that one day does make a difference you might not you might tell yourself
It doesn't make a difference, but there's that there's something in there is every day of training
You can get matters every day counts you can't get it back, and if you miss it
You miss it especially like right now alright. Well. I've been traveling a lot lately way more than normal
So I know like if I gotta get there. I get my rounds in
Got to get my rounds it. That's the way it's got to be and part of that is my ego
brothers my ego saying look I
Gotta just you know I gotta fight. I got a straw gonna be stay on top
We gotta stay on top of the mountain as high as I can like hungry minds and the young bucks are out there
They're coming after me. Yes. I appreciate that mmm, but that keeps me in check
My ego the positive party he goes that I do I do want to win mhm and I don't want to get beat
Now that being said guess who I trained with my train with all the guys that most likely to beat me
That's what I want
I want to have that happen so there's a balance there's a good balance there and at the end of the day
there's really no escaping, and I think it's real prevalent like for you and Dean and the
It's really prevalent. We're sure you have all that you have all those thoughts
You know in your head or whatever?
But it all comes in the whole reason you have that thought is to get better at Julie for sure
It's yeah, because I when you start jiu-jitsu you like some people say even me like well
You know I'll just I just want to get good enough to like you know be able to defend myself
Well after six months, man, you're good
So what am I doing here 25 years later still didn't save dad
Because like there's a couple guys that I will I you know I want to keep ahead of or even with or catch
You know like that's what's driving. So there's there's a definite ego thing involved
but I
Think the other where that goes too far the ego goes too far
This is an obvious answer is like oh, I don't really you know
I'm not gonna train with that guy because he might catch me right then now you're not now you're not progressing now
You're in this thing that he's talking about like you're not gonna progress because you're not gonna train with that first or you're not gonna
Take any risks whatsoever so you're just gonna defend defend, and you're like oh, I survived around and I'm out of here
Yeah, so you got a you you got to keep that attitude of like hey, I'm gonna get beat. Yeah
And you know that's the thing jujitsu works, man
Yeah, jujitsu works. If somebody catches you yeah doesn't matter who they are right they catch
You jujitsu works you tap out you go again. That's the beautiful thing about jujitsu yes. That's the beautiful thing about life
Cuz in life. You're not gonna win every time you're gonna. Call it
You're gonna make mistakes someone's gonna capitalize on them, so what are you gonna? Do you give up and even more important than that?
You can lose
You can lose is whatever thing you're trying to do you can lose you're trying to start a new business you can lose you're trying
To get a new job, you can lose
You can lose in life
So are you gonna?
Prevent that from even getting you
let that prevent you from even getting on the mat in the first place on even trying to start a new business even trying to
Try to do something that's outside your comfort zone
That's what this that's what this is saying get outside of your comfort zone. Yeah, don't sit there. It's not gonna
Help you yeah
And you can see it with with the guys who you can tell or just focus on like being the guy who be?
The other guy kind of thing then I'll do those kinds of things
They'll roll and then when they after you know two three rounds when they're they feel their steam kind of going down the leave
Where they'll sit on the side and talk you mean like I'm not rolling anymore
We're the only real small guys did that - Andy yesterday what we did like six rounds
And I was like Brian ease our backup because you know he's training for events you know
I'm like I'm I'm gonna give I was like hey. I called dr. Luke. I'm like dr. Luke
Give me some help over here, and he's a backup. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, you know cuz
gotta got to get him to step it up but
What's interesting or what the reality is when I have the time or when I'm not when I have the time, but like I?
Always get my rounds in - like
We're doing if we got two guys that are competing and we're doing you know two and one out
Like I put them through and then I go through it - because I want to get my training because I'm trying to get better
- right to your point yeah, you're not in there
I'm trying to get better yeah, and that's exactly what I mean, and it's obvious you know
But you know you know it's a big symptom of someone who's who's focusing on the wrong thing is like
If they don't do well or whatever and they say stuff like oh you're lucky
This is in MMA or something like that or they're like they're unhappy about the fact that they got pressured by you specific
Like a cetera this guy will remain nameless um
And that's what he'd always say like oh. Yeah, if there were strikes. I would have won kind of thing
You'd say that kind of stuff all the time. I was like brah
Focusing on the wrong thing right now the fact that you quote-unquote got beat, or I beat you
And this is how you would've beat me. You know you focused on the wrong thing
why do you think I do cuz I do this I do the opposite when I roll with someone and
I'll be like hey you know like I'll catch him or whatever
I'll back. Yeah, you know hey if this was MMA like let's say I'm gonna remember fighter catching. I'll be like hey
You know if this is MMA
You know you're on top for a while you didn't you'd have been pounding me in the face
I would've been good you would want more if I'm going against jiu-jitsu guy and I catch him or something
I'll be like yeah, you know though if that was points though
You were up like eight points you probably beat me that was a that took me 15 minutes to get so you wouldn't want yeah
And it CIA obviously, I don't know exactly what's been on your head, but it seems like
That would be something you'd say to someone to make them kind of feel better because you know
It's a little mini competition in there for real
I mean
That's essentially what makes it so good because he's giving you an accurate look how in a motivated opponent attack or whatever would look like
He's going full-speed against you so there is that element of like we're competing against each other and when you lose this kind of light
Loss to this guy especially if you're not that used to training or or so I'm just being nice you're being nice
I think yes, and at the same time if you've seen stuff like hey if he this was MMA
You'd be pounding me or something like that that there could be a little element of your own training kind of like you just went
To lots like yeah, I kept that in mind
Where you know? I would have got hit there
And you're just kind of voicing it may be for the benefit of yourself as well as the day
I don't know that that's what it seems like what happened. It's almost thinking those things Chuck well
You know that's we could go on this book for a long time. I think that's a good place to
Reflect and say look there's a lot of principles that you can apply judo, and Jiu Jitsu. There's things that Jiu Jitsu
Should you should take from Jiu Jitsu and things that you should take from judo principles?
And if you mix those two together you still get something that's really powerful not just on the mat
But something that's really powerful to apply to your life
Again is everything in this Theory's perfect. No
Somebody asked me that the other day. I was with a group of
young leaders and
Someone because I was talking about how it's beneficial to read about history and understand warfare and understand it gives you an insight into human
Nature because you insight into people the way people think and all this stuff, and this guy says hey, do you ever think that?
Maybe what you read was wrong
And if you apply what what was you read you'll actually end up making a mistake
Or do you just follow what you know history, and I'm like no
that's the whole reason I
Go because the more you read the more you understand the more different angles you see and I'm questioning every decision
I make I'm questioning all these things all the time, and I'm using all these different
information that I have in my head as sounding boards to check off of
Like what well at least let me shed some light on it gather some intelligence. That's what that's what I'm trying to do
So yeah question yourself and question these theories. That's what I think that's one of the best things about
It's one of the best things about MMA and jujitsu and fighting right now is that it's evolving so fast
And and and it's open for it, and if you're not down for that right now
You're gonna be left in the dust you're gonna be left in the dust does this mean that every fancy new move that comes out
Should be applied to your game. No it doesn't mean that at all does it mean that every fancy
GG Jitsu move that you saw in Worlds would be super effective in a fist fight
No, it doesn't mean that at all
But should you have an open mind to understand that some of those things could be absolutely beneficial um yes?
You definitely should so keep an open mind with everything that you're doing
You know that idea of broad-mindedness sometimes. I wish Kano would have had a little bit more broad-mindedness
Yeah
Cuz that would you know it would have been beneficial you know that's one of the sad things about judo as they they outlawed
The double leg takedown in judo you can't do it. You can do it after you've done another
Takedown attempt so it can be like a follow-on gotcha, but that's not cool. No
That's not cool
And it's the same thing with with jiu-jitsu right when they outlaw certain submissions like the the heel hook with G Jiu Jitsu Yeah
Right like the heel hook is still there the heel hook itself
Is still there in the in the?
The motion of yeah that area you shouldn't a lot
It should be part of it because then you have people ending up in positions where they're not effective fighting positions
They're not because you can get heel hook in your gear never torn apart. Yeah, so why would you outlaw something?
That's very effective. It's it's I
Understand there is some danger in the heel hook for those of you that don't know the danger of the heel hook is that it?
Doesn't create pain before it creates industry it injury well
It doesn't create a lot of pain before it creates industry in injury
so you can feel you can have a heel hook on you and you can be like oh I can get out of this and
The person starts applying pressuring you like oh that doesn't really hurt and then pop your get your you have to go get surgery now
Yeah, that's the problem with heel hooks
But if you and your training partners understand that and if competitors understood like hey if I get caught here
I'm gonna end up in surgery if I don't tap yeah
So that's the if you understand that then you won't go in these positions that where you're exposed to heel so
That's what you should do not only with jiu-jitsu, but you should do with life to like understand. What really works
Don't outlaw things don't avoid things just because you're not good at yeah, open yourself up to him
Do you know why they don't come? They really don't allow heel hooks in ghee competition. Do you know? Why are you asking?
Yeah, but you know the reality that they say I think it's because the the possibility of injury. Yeah the nogi
They let it lie because you can slide more
And I don't know and I think that's I think that might be just tradition
But hopefully you know they should allow double leg takedown Xin judo. They should allow heel hooks and jiu-jitsu
In engage it's ooh. Now this doesn't mean if you roll with me, and we're rolling G you
just slap a heel hook on me because I
Won't be expecting that and I'll be pissed or that should be part of training yeah
And so congratulate is oh yeah, I guess you're right. I can't tighten it up
Yeah, let's see that is one of those thing
here's what it is with the helix Wiggy like if someone Busta cuz it's so widely known as as a
Mouthful yeah, it's a so if you get a guys especially. Let's say extreme scenario a new guy comes in he's a purple belt
Hungry blue belt he comes in he rolls with you know one of the instructors black belt or whatever ye
You know they're rolling and he's going super hard and he goes for a heel hook
pause right there
Technically the what what as far as what we're talking about that should be okay. We're all here training. We're all getting better
He's going hard. Thank thanks for the good training kind of thing he did a but we're
essentially trained to see heel hooks with the Gil as
Disrespect yeah, it's against the rules you have to go
It's so embedded in it so it's embedded in the culture really, but really but as far as what we're talking about
Like it's it's really. Okay. You know yeah
look I'll
Say no, that's not okay. No
Contradictory for me because but this is the similar thing right if you if you came into the gym and like
You went for heel hook on me. We were training key, and I started punching in the face
Right that like like you weren't expecting that, but you should be prepared for it
So there is a virus if you understand that that's what your training like Oh?
Are we Street rules punches legal allowed what I'm saying. There's there's certain things that are
Universally as far as I I have not been anywhere
And I talk to a lot of people I roll a lot of different to places where it's like you're wearing a geek
You're it's you're you're cleared hot to do heel hooks. Yeah. I have not seen that anywhere me neither
It should be that way well. I mean Chris
Technica thing is I'm with you and you know there's exceptions of course and just because I happened is it Craig Craig Baker
Will allow even say yeah, yeah
You can he look it doesn't come up because just like never saying it's so widely known and understood from the beginning
Yeah, you don't do heel hooks with Iggy. It's just but why is that we don't really think about
Why is that and doesn't want because those are the?
recognized
Sanctioned rules right just like the recognized sanction rules say that if we're grappling. I'm not gonna start punching you in the face
No, but I know because that's punching in the face in that grappling like if he it punching in the face does deviate from when?
You when you start learning to do - unless?
It's understood that that's the kind of training you're gonna get so here's the thing okay when I put on the eat these root these
Moves are not allowed, right?
There's no
Yeah, I don't know there's no rules
I mean sure IBJJF
but you know muscle is a
Probably bigger percentage of people that do jiu-jitsu have never competed in IBJJF tournament probably the majority people yet
We're following IBJJF rules in training sometimes
Even though actually the key competitions, I've never heard of Aggie competition that allows he looks yeah, you know
But who that's not the point the point isn't that they're not allowed so don't do them
That's not the point the point is why are they not allowed given what we're just talking about there
in my opinion, they're not allowed because of the
propensity or a possibility of an injury or
People think that there's a high possibility you could get injured they're in here
They're somewhat accurate because it is a different kind of pain
It was a lack of pain, and so there's a little bit accuracy. Yeah, I dig it and I see if you know
Specially if that is true as far as why they want it because some people might sit. They don't want it because
jiu-jitsu was always looked at as this linear thing like Donna Donna mentioned kind of mentioned part of this where
You know you get past the legs and you work your way up his body to tap them out
and you can start tapping them out when you get up to the upper body and
The legs were just something you had to get past because they're gonna try to kick you and you know they have leverage on their
Own body and all this stuff, and that's it. That's traditionally. How we look at jiu-jitsu and that's the effectiveness
this is the best and all this stuff now you get you know a new person or
Someone from samba or whatever will come in and be like oh, that's jiu-jitsu or let me go ahead and kind of
Flip it upside down a little bit invasions what this jiu-jitsu and they're like we don't like that kind of thing yeah
That could be why I'm just saying that's what every why yeah
Could be why could I ask you this I have I have heard like that
People's initial reaction I think I've heard Dean's here. That's like if your reaction is like. Oh, that's not good for my game
We'll just outlawed yeah, but that's what it resulted here cuz all jiu-jitsu guys are training this way
You don't did hey do you double leg takedown SAR not good for judo?
Against a wrestler you get someone that's been wrestling for
27 years and they come and do judo competition, they hit a double leg, it's not good for the judo player yeah
They're so guess. What kind of thing yeah, and so guess what out long
Yeah, which is a bummer right and so yeah? I'm not. I'm not pro out long. That was the ultimate point there
That's what I heard of so let me ask you this do you think in training Hugh hooks with the gay just you personally?
You think they should be allowed
he looks we think he I think they should be allowed every time all the time everywhere but
They are not right now and therefore in my mentality is like okay
Because I'm not gonna put myself into a position that a heel
Hook is available to you unless I know that they're not available exactly yeah, I did and I dig in and actually I agree
That's the same thing like like if we were gonna roll, and I just did it no good
but if I said hey
Before we rolled like one we're walking there even right before we kind of you know shook hands, whatever
I said hey Hugh, hooks are a go
That would change the game. Yeah, we change the game for sure so same thing like if you're doing noogie
And you know guys like they just don't know or whatever. They'll grab your shorts. They'll grab your shirt rash guard or whatever
They'll grab it
You know because they just don't know even if you it's the same deal less dangerous of course
But same deal where it's like when you start doing that they'll stop be like hey you can't do that kind of thing
But if you say before you roll hate yeah, you can grab shorts or whatever up to you
Just don't pull them off or something like that. It's kind of one of those deals
Yeah, you could I guess make some ad hoc rules before you start rolling, but yeah
Or just go with what's universally accepted at this time
Slaps in the face or legal sometimes. It's cool. Whatever check all right?
Well like I said a lot of stuff to learn from
Judo and Jiu Jitsu to make yourself better in
those sports
and in life so good yeah, but the I
I was actually pretty. I don't think impress, but pretty yeah impress, but the whole book yeah
Yeah, except for the part about telling people how to eat telling people how to eat the calisthenics are no good
Yeah, being buff is a waste of time. There's definitely some and is some truth to that or this
It's weird cuz as I'm preparing the podcast. I'm like okay. Do I just
Say the things in here that I agree with oh, yeah, yeah, that's one way I could do it
Do I because one thing that's I I was thinking about when I read a quote from a book people?
Do they kind of think like well I agree with that like I support this unless I?
Outwardly just reject it yeah, and I kind of did half the book where I was like well
You know I don't want to talk about that because I see where he's coming from but that's not really my gig
And then I got to other parts
I was like I have to talk about the fact that he thinks that this stuff is you know this is a completely different than
What I think you know yeah, so yeah, I guess I try and explain myself as I talk about it, but yeah
There's there's definitely some things that that I don't agree with there's some things that I don't agree with about about judo like
You know there's things that I don't agree with about jujitsu I think that's why I think
There's a good mixture of the two that would be very powerful
Bring we need to bring Dave camera on yeah
You know some of these other guys that have grown up in judo and are savage at jujitsu yeah
Okay
Anyways, cool well speaking of you know getting better in jiu-jitsu and getting better in life sure any suggestions on
How people could get better yes, so when you get when you start doing jiu-jitsu
Okay, you're gonna get that's probably one of the one two three maybe four
Questions you're gonna have the first four what kind of gear get you get that's gonna be one of them. That's my guess
That's my prediction
Um sure you can be in jiu-jitsu and still say hey gee should I get you know whatever anyway?
Here's the answer Origen you get an Origin Heat. That's what you do
Because they are factually
Factually see a rigid and being right. There's actually the best keys they're all made in America by the way
Different types of G's there they got some new stuff by the way Pete. Just sent me some new stuff
It's not that new they're just different like styles. It's not geese it's what I get some sweats. Oh, okay, which happened to me
Happened to be the most comfortable sweats
In mics you said you knew you said to me. Sorry, bro. You know something must be joggers
But nonetheless back to the geese yeah get them at origin man calm. That's a good one support yourself
Support the Jews it's support life
support of America America yes they're made in America you know
From the dirt to this shirt from the dirty t-shirt the cotton that has grown in America gets
It turns into Iggy somehow Pete does that part isn't it kind of cool to think that when you put on a geek like there's?
That Becky came from a factory in Maine came from from a factory in Maine that was built
specifically to make jiu-jitsu jeez and that there's
People up there the workers up there craftsmen up there that are sewing that ghee for you
And then it gets put from Maine into a bag and sent to you isn't that kind of right it is yeah?
Not like Kennedy Kennedy have soul
I'm gonna ask you that question Kenickie have soul
We don't know the answer that
Yes, yeah
But we can make it an assessment from the outside and if Agee has soul then you'd want that soul become from Maine
Right and if certain Keys had souls and some G's didn't have souls you would for sure want the gear with the soul yes
Understanding, and if keys do indeed have souls which I tend to believe they do they could then you'd want the good souls
The American soul for me
Yep
Well if Pete starts making shoes you'll know that they'll have souls
Wow
Echo made of funny
MLS or domain.com, that's where you get them also in jiu-jitsu, okay?
We gotta be honest here in jiu-jitsu its physical you twist your arms your neck your body not twist like injure it
But you know it gets some work
Yeah, and with work needs recovery with recovery comes supplementation good supplementation krill oil
I feel like I said the word krill oil probably more than I've said any other food
Item or dietary supplement in my whole life good. I'm tired, too
Happy about it because of how the benefices got it got more krill oil, too
By the way from Pete with the joggers which are nice by the way
Also another one called joint where for these are all Jaco supplements by the way if you didn't know super krill
That's just regular super chocolate super girl joint warfare, which is another
formula for joint maintenance
Reconstruction someone said hey, I got knee surgery is this gonna help me
Yes, yes, it will help your knee recover. Especially the meniscus situation Julie
Yeah, oh, yeah, okay, anything we're okay, so money. I'm not gonna. Go too. Deep into it, but
Anything involving cartilage like these squid that don't get a bunch of blood flow oh
yes, they tend to degenerate over well everything degenerates, but
Over time ik not for everyone
Ya know complacency right no back. You know nonetheless joint warfare
That's a good one maintain the joints and this goes for any kind of physical activity
Your joints will thank you, or you'll thank your joints. You'll think Jocko for jock will krill oil and joint warfare also
Discipline not just regular discipline is a supplement discipline. It's a pre
mission
Cognitive enhancing because people were making stuff that helped you physically like a pre-workout and then they were making nootropics
That would help you mentally like your cognition sure and well in my job
Especially my old job guess what I needed both. Yeah. I needed to be mentally sharp, and I needed to be physically sharp
Yeah, so I wanted everything in the same like mix sure blend
That's why we made the discipline yeah, and you didn't want to do the pre-workout and then boom and then okay
Let me go in the other one right here
Okay, the home, and then you know you want to get them both get them both one time one hit
One win and you feel it, and it feels good
Yeah, that's what like yesterday is talking about the rounds
I did yeah
Cuz I knew I was coming down as I was gonna pay the man saw sure hit the discipline
Yeah tastes good too. By the way. Yeah, yeah tastes amazingly good. What's interesting about it? Is that spunk fruit?
Yeah, it's monk fruit. You know about monk fruit. No monk fruit is the sweetener that's used in discipline
It's like whatever eighty seven thousand times, sweeter than sugar, but it's just as a root but a little bit
so you only need a little tiny bit in there low glycemic and
next slow omelet lacing the glycemic it doesn't give you the
insulin spike
And we'll just say and that's good oh yeah, and just so people know there's caffeine in it
But there's only 15 milligrams of caffeine so you're not gonna get jittery but you get a little a little micro dose
Yeah, I've gets a little help a little little health weather
But monk food. Also it like helps in eight. It's it's legit. Yeah
It's called discipline tastes good because jock wants it to taste good
Yeah, that kind of freaked you out he had through mail for sure he thought maybe I just want things to taste horrible
So that's more discipline not black you. I like that
I was like interesting that that was part of the focus, but hey good. I say good
Well, you're gonna be really happy that I have this attitude when the when the protein comes out sure in chocolate
Yeah, the mint chocolate chip, you know
just FYI mm-hmm, it's not normal and
It's got the monk fruit in it so that's the sweetener so it tastes delish
and
It doesn't taste like anything else
There's no way that it could taste this good, and and be what it is Scott yeah
Yeah, I just made up I had to make up my own name for it. Yeah. Yeah, dig it you did the right thing?
It's called Molk
Mo LK with the oom lot over the oh you know why tripping to Motorhead?
Mayor's good, man. I think that's good so yeah pretty soon people gonna be on the mold when is that a couple weeks?
We've got it we went through the final testing. It's so uh it's so it tastes good
It's easy to digest easy all the good things. Yeah, cuz and they so remember back in especially it smoke
Yeah, the kind of something you need this is like
I don't even know what to say this isn't it's not like a chocolate milkshake. It's not like a protein shake
It's like but it's like
Mega mass, I think was five thousand or three
Thousand was it five thousand probably no. I was one thousand two thousand five hundred it might have been okay
I think that was at South Park those five thousand right double super colostrum seven
Nonetheless it was super delicious. It was like a big like dog food bag full of mega mass
What five hundred or whatever it was?
Chocolate you drink it and it tastes straight up like a chocolate milkshake and guess what it probably was just a G
I was gonna say that's the thing that's yeah. These are all kind of like quote health foods nowadays
I call this approach you look at the look at the thing on a protein bar
Yeah, and compare the protein bar to a Snickers bar. Yeah, it's like the same content inside of it
Uh, yeah, whatever yes, be careful. I saw a hell. It's cool. That's what was cool about discovering the monk fruit
Is being able to make stuff tastes really good without having the crap?
Artificial sweeteners in it yeah in a way, that's kind of going back to your roots, right?
That's where where it's like. Okay. We got sweetness sweetness is a thing it's a natural thing. We'd like it
You know for a reason all this stuff cool man. Don't do away with the sweetness
Yeah, but you know when you start engineering foods to like to do kind of like the advertising
I was talking about the wait. Maybe I should come up with something that just tastes horrible
You just have to gut check to taste it just to test yourself mentally. Yeah. Yeah, see how good that?
Oh, yeah
Gotcha, nonetheless, that's gonna be available the Molk
Is gonna be available in a few weeks apparently yeah?
From the joint where fur and super krill and this is a good idea by the way do the subscription their recurring
We're eight kids
So you don't got to remember get down to your last three pills cuz you don't know if you have like six pills
That's two days in my case
I don't know how many you take but I mean?
I know how many you take but I don't know how many other people do you get six pills in there?
You don't know how many pills in there you go one pill, okay?
I know there's only one at that time too late even six pills technically it's almost too late pretty much you go subscription
Don't worry about that stuff boom get the subscription
Also, like we said geese rash guards compression gear joggers
Most comfortable ones in the world in my experience. I don't know maybe there's a more comfortable one
Maybe not if there is I have never seen it do the job just have a soul
Probably felt like it
They touched your soul
Be comforted it for over a hundred percent hundred percent or gin main calm good way to support also
in Maine
the Jiu Jitsu
Immersion camp you immerse yourself in jiu-jitsu for half a week great half a week and a half a week
There's like two sessions. Can you do both sessions? Yes, you can I mean is that like a thing of course? Oh?
Yeah, okay, so there's an option for that boom one week immersion into jujitsu just learning. You know it's not like
Boot camp were like you know you're gonna be forced to do a bunch of calisthenics, which we don't advocate apparently anymore
Kono still we still advocate counseling
I had the key Kells especially like a burpee situation which I think is I advocate all kinds of cows all calisthenics
Actually, you can't show me a calisthenic that I don't advocate even though people like are like suit ups are no good
They work, your psoas mostly. Don't even know I advocate them, too. I like strong sauce muscles. Yeah, yeah good
Yeah, just tell me they were like oh that doesn't even work your abs. It works your still has muscles like cool
I've strong psoas muscles next question for Soph yes. They do work your abs trading trade. Don't do sit-ups for one year
Yeah, well your other stuff and then do
Five sets of burnout sit-ups, and then see if your abs are so in the next day. Don't see that
Mean to failure hug, that's a burnout. Can you even do sit-out sit-ups to failure oh?
Yeah, it's hard and it's gonna burn how much time you gotta have you have the whole day
Here's the throw the point isn't how many sit-ups you can do or don't can't do the point is that people saying?
Sit-ups don't do your ab muscles
you know
They do that too, but they do you have muscles nonetheless I agree with you
Do you do jumping jacks? Yeah? I do jumping jacks to actually do jumping jacks last week
You're part of a metcon, but still there was an old old team guy workout
Jumping jacks pull-ups, I'm sorry jumping jacks push-ups
You just do jumping jacks and push-ups, and you think it's no big deal
And then like you're 45 minutes into it like I hate jumping jacks and push-ups
Yeah, I don't know if I'd ever do something continuously for 45 minutes. Yeah, well that leave it at your first half of that workout
Yeah, I don't get especially have to do anything to get any exercise and you can make it suck after 45 minutes
Yeah, like there's I came to think of an exercise. It doesn't suck after 45, but you know he's doing buds neck rotations
Just do that in the teams - yeah, you're laying down. I was like you're like okay
I'm just gonna lay down and move my head around Oh laying down. Yeah. I never you lay down neck rotations one two
Yeah, ya do that for 45 hours
You're like this is the dumbest thing I've ever done life, but glad we're doing it. Yeah
yeah, I think you're right about that sure the
Met. Well I figured that key would be if you don't like the whole 45 minutes thing is you do something
That's hard enough of a movement that you don't have to do 45 minutes
Yeah, that's that's good. If you don't want to just do something like socks before five minutes. I did a metcon like just kind of
Representative of what you were talking about earlier where it was
It was like how many of this these two movements you can do within a certain amount of time
Yeah, so I said which was different usually I set my rest time to a certain time
And I do them in full and yeah, that's a good good little changeup
Yeah, do that
Or you can do the jumping jacks and pull-ups push-ups swoosh, I mean you wouldn't even have pull-up bars, so we're like Amish
Straightening the ship or something yeah, okay jumping jacks push-ups, yeah
Nonetheless back to origin jujitsu camp. You won't be doing jumping jacks push-ups
100% unless you want to you then you can you know, but it's more learning Jiu Jitsu practicing Jiu Jitsu
No pressure unless you put some pressure on yourself, which I recommend
Yeah, do that by the way and roll with everybody you know do some what's the word?
What's the rolling randori randori will be doing some randori?
Yeah, good let it good in straw be there. Oh, you'll be there. I will be there Dave Burke is gonna be deeper
Big-time he's got the bug. Yeah. Yeah, I
Haven't talked to JP and or Lafe
See if they're gonna roll up and roll oh, but the camp. Yeah. Yeah make sense
Yeah, nonetheless. It is August 26 through September 2nd
of this year
also
speaking of boring workouts
jakka, workouts doing 45 minutes the jumping jacks and push-ups
I don't think so
But if you want to interesting where actually I shouldn't I shouldn't give you
Give you crap about it because I did look on your Instagram, and you had like some Bulgarian bag
Yeah on there, so you got a you vary your workout your workout gets interesting
Okay, I think it credit so if you want to make your work out interesting get some new movements new equipment
And they're gonna audit dot-com
Jaco
junco
Go in there get you some good kettle bells even though kettle bells. I guess ultimately could be viewed as boring
You can make them boring yeah, yeah, that's kind of your boring. Yeah, you know what ultimately that's really what it is
Because even me doing the same metcon that I do all the time all I did was switch up like one teeny tiny thing
So it's more about me than the workout, or it was work up about the equipment less about the equipment more about me
Nonetheless if you want to make it about the equipment Anna has the equipment maces
Steel bells see I haven't even done that that's like some advanced creativity stuff. You know battle ropes all this stuff
that'll get you functional strength and
actual strength
Just joking bonus. You know anyway on it calm chuckle good spot
Not a good info on there as well also when you get this book called
mind over muscle
I'm gonna list it up. Can you get it on Amazon? Yep? Okay? I'm gonna listen on the website talk about lessons
I've talked down to me from the ancient
Book before that wasn't available
Old-school style looks nonetheless not this one when you get it. Don't worry go to occupatus calm
I'll put it in the book section with all the books boom click through there. Good way to support and you get the book boom
Also, if you do another shopping good continue doing that get to leaf blower
It's about to be actually gonna be summer before fall
Huh so so maybe get a weed whacker weed whacker some sunscreen some surf shorts
Yeah, yeah get all that stuff. Good way to support and support yourself also
Subscribe to the podcast if you haven't already itunes stitcher google play whatever your preferred podcast
listening
device slash
Application is subscribe good way to support
also
If you want to leave your review don't hesitate on that one do Kano says
Make a decision about leaving review make a decision and just go don't hesitate on the review. Just do it leave it
Like everything in life. You know reviews no different
Also on YouTube subscribe to our YouTube channel if you want if you care
even a little bit about the video version of this podcast and what chocolate looks like and
I don't care if you care about what I look like but again, and I still get this by the way
I guess apparently I don't look how I sound
Easier like can you match up a voice to a face you kinda can't huh?
Yeah, you can yeah like you for sure, but it's not like a one-to-one
It's kind of like a like you hear the voice
And then there's this ambiguous kind of group of faces that might go with it. You know it's one of those deals
It's not just one face comes to mind and that's kind of it's not that
But it's like I guess my face falls way outside of the group of faces that
practically
May not practically, but that that's probably
Probably match my voice, I guess that's that's what I hear too apparently I still hear it so if you care
Subscribe to the YouTube channel, I guess technically you wouldn't have to subscribe to you just look at it
But if you want to support at the same time if you want subscribe to the podcast on YouTube
Also, you have excerpts on there, so that's another reason by the way
You know you want to share these shorter excerpts with people and watch them
well
YouTube is the place to do it also some enhanced excerpts
That's what I'm calling them today enhance put some music on there. Make you feel good about it
Here's the thing you advocate discipline like the way you feel doesn't matter. I'll say this it matters less then discipline
It still doesn't matter. Yeah when you're fired up and go do work on that
Whatever when you're fired up to go do a workout versus the day when you really don't want to do a work guys it then
All the time people like oh, I didn't want to work out today
But I did anyways and I set a PR in my whatever. Yeah, why does that happen that happens sometimes?
You know no get up. No. I wasn't I wasn't that it wasn't that theory
If you feel like work you know and you're fired up to go work out
That's gonna be a good workout. Chances are not all the time I get it
If you really don't feel like working on your dragging ass
dragging you got
5.5 hours of sleep and you're not chocolate by the way and
You're
You ate some Snickers or something like this and you're like dang
I still got to work out you really don't feel like it and you have a bunch of other stuff to do
And you go work out ever talk about snickerdoodle
Know what I mean. I know what us little is this guy and the team's whose name happened to be Nick Scherr
And we were like new guys, and we went on a compass course the only food that he brought out in the field was was
Snickers like you know like the 12-pack of Snickers
Sure, yeah as soon brought he bought like three 12 packs of stickers, and though that's all he brought for five days
It didn't go down well. No yeah, Owen thinks he got a mega diarrhea case
So the whole market on his nickname was snickerdoodle after that oh
Yeah, snickerdoodle stay pretty funny. Yeah, and was already bummed out actually after that one
It's good. We had a guy named Snickers on our football team nuh Snickers
He was like to use the center or that was his last name know his nickname full on but I did that's how
You know how certain guys have their nickname is so strong. You don't really you know like you yeah
It was like that nonetheless back to the point if you're fired up to go work out
chances are you can have a better workout same thing with the
Chocolates message if you're fired up to listen to it it might sink in better might you put some good music on it
Boom might see getting better it might not enough enhance, so it's enhanced
You know special messages nonetheless the point there is subscribe to youtube channel if you want good way to support
Also, choco is the store it's called chocolate or chocolate or dot-com patches are in that's been heating me up. I
Haven't seen beanies on there. Yeah, you know process well. Here's the thing I got a boom right in time for July
So we got that going for us. I'm just a job hey, man
You know better late than never I guess those in the meantime apply when it's summertime and you get to be
It does not apply maybe I'll get the thin ones that straight lady do it for
Nothing better about it
No doubt about it Hey look you're right, and we're still gonna work hard on the beanies and get them get them out quality
Can't rush
Great greatness quality, dude. Do you know what a nine months for that's not about Russia's
Quality like mega quality those things could have been knitted from cashmere
Yeah
All right, well, I'm gonna continue to work and you know when they're out they're gonna be out. They're gonna be fantastic
They better be all right there you go amazing in the meantime
Maybe it takes a lot to get a a soul into a baby. Yep. Yeah, it could be
In the meantime do some cool shirts on there. I think they're cool does one equals four you. Don't get after it
That's a good one
Simple to the point back to the book next year, that's a new one
Put other titles yeah, all of them on the back well all the book titles up until the point yeah
So what's nothing to what podcast freaking you should figure that out. That's like a layer. Yeah
Yeah, the first hundred, but you probably didn't do that. I think we're Nona knows. I conjured something layers been missed
That's fine, because then we could've put it on another back of the book at 200. Yeah like the updated list layer
Yeah, yeah
Maybe maybe not or maybe I'll add a layer cuz layers are animal
Edible, maybe you can add layers you see what I'm saying um anyway some shirts on there some rash guards on there some
Patches there like I said some women's stuff on their hoodies
also
Decals, you know what decal is Jesse's decals Jesse's decals. Here's the thing with decals
Where they're they're essentially a sticker right, and we all know it because I and I understand, but he uses
like this
Stuff like the material for this decal is like supposed to survive the apocalypse
Like that kind decals, okay?
Good way to support Jessie didn't play around no not at all and this guy is like Hughes like we you know we go back
And forth and he's like yeah, I make decals like yeah, that's a good idea whatever and then
Another company called. I think it was called Ashland front something like this
they got some decals and I was like dang these decals and
Obviously prompted me to okay we need our decals they were legit. They are legit, and they're on jockle store
Calm vinyl a good way to support if you want something get something also psychological warfare
If you don't know what that is this one is it's an album with tracks of
Jocko helping you through this is what the track is it's a it's not a music track
It's Jocko on there every track helping you get through your moment of weakness
and we have them I have
Jocko has them mmm even though he you know is reluctant to admit that from time to time
And what it does is let's say you're gonna skip the workout. I think skipping workout
This is my opinion skip and work out and cheat not cheating on a dike you cheat on a diet technically yes
Yeah, it's like you're cheating
Anyway, yeah, you betrayed your yourself. You know cuz you have a future self
Seemed saying like your self of right now
We'll make like a protocol right and then your future self essentially cheats on your yeah, yeah, I saw some meme of Homer Simpson
Saying like all this guy's futures not looking good
So yeah technically it is if you're cheating on your past self on the diet
Don't worry about that you start feeling that feeling coming come along you got a track for that you just listen to it
And it's essentially like chocolate telling you why?
You shouldn't slip why shouldn't slip down that slippery slope and whatever activity some good ones on there procrastination all that stuff
Yeah, check that one out good way to support very effective to that's on iTunes Apple
Music no I am those on Amazon music Google Play Apple iTunes wherever you can get
Mp3s that's where you can get it. Also you can get from Amazon. You can get jakka white tea
It tastes really good
It does have 15 grams of caffeine so that's a little micro dose
That's why I put 15 grams of caffeine inside the discipline because that was the dose that I like
It has but but it's only 15 milligrams, so you don't get jittery it. Also has a high level of antioxidants
That's what the pomegranate does. That's why it's a pomegranate white tea and of course in addition to those things
It is the only white tea that comes the guaranteed eight thousand pound been left
Elite so that's good you got that going for you even Jordan Peterson now
You know I got a text from him and he's up to 8,000
So because he was plateaued at 7,000 pounds as he admitted on PI he isn't like to admit his weaknesses either
But there was yeah, it's hard 7,000 pounds
Pretty pretty sad Brooks
No now he's 8,000 so good for him. Oh good. Yeah, all took us a little chuckle whitey also
We got some books. I got some books
I got a I got a book called weigh the warrior kid the principles of
Being a warrior and really of being a good human being and they're in there, and they are simple and they're clear enough for it
six-year-old a seven-year-old an eight-year-old an 80 year old
To understand them and it gets better because this story continues in the book way the war your kid to
Marks mission and this book starts to hit on some other principles in life
Keeping your emotions under control
working hard being frugal saving money and also dealing with Nathan James
Nathan James
New bully psychological bully a little bit different mark wants to fight him
Mark figures have been training jiu-jitsu. I'm gonna fight this guy, but instead uncle G Uncle Jake says
No, you can fight him first you have to gather intelligence on him
You have to figure out
What's going on?
with
Nathan James
Understand why he's your enemy and see if there's another way to solve this problem beef besides fighting
Turns out to be very good. Also mark has the jujitsu tournament coming up and guess what he doesn't want to compete in it
He doesn't want to do his first Jiu Jitsu tournament. Why?
because he's
He's afraid of losing he's afraid of failing fear of failure. That's bad, so he's got all these problems
How did he overcome them well luckily uncle Jake's in the house?
Uncle Jake is out for the summertime gives them a hand
Order that book is going to be available April 24th
Same thing with all the other books
Well the last two books that have come out
It's gonna sell out the publisher doesn't understand. How many books to make they want to hedge their bets
So they're just gonna make a certain amount
so
The more people order now first of all you'll get it when it comes out and second of all they'll know that they need to
make more and
Order it from wherever order it from Amazon order it from Barnes Noble, but go into your local book store
This is a mission go to your local book store and tell me you want the book
Mark's mission way the warrior kid to tell them you want that
That will help spread the word
And also while you're helping out war your kids check out Irish Oaks ranch calm we can get soap
You've made by young Aiden
Who's only 12 years old he's got his own business and the soap isn't just any soap it's good so
Then he actually called the Jocko soap and the jock was so pomato that I made up
anything gets no credit for this the motto is stay clean and
Someone said there's a layer in that
steak
lean
Lean that's clean so layers no big deal
Yeah, also don't forget about the discipline equals freedom Field Manual
this is the manual for getting after it thoughts and actions that will keep you off the
Slippery slope and to keep you on the path
the path of discipline and
Thereby as the title says the path of freedom if you want the audio version of that it's not on audible
It's an album with tracks
discipline equals freedom
Field Manual on iTunes Amazon music Google Play, that's where you can get it and also extreme ownership
combat leadership broken down into
pragmatic strategies and tactics that you can apply to your business in life boom
Still on the Amazon bestseller list still on wall street journal' keeping it real
and if you want
Or you need to take it to the next level Ashlin front is my leadership and management consulting company the overwhelming
Factor in the success of any business or team is leadership. That's what it is and
at Ashkelon front we come to your company and
Train and align your leadership so that you work effectively together as a team to dominate
Your battlefield. It's me
It's my brother lave babban JP. Danelle Dave Burke
You can email info and echelon front comm or visit the website
Ashland front comm and of course the muster is our leadership seminar or only doing two this year
Washington DC May 17th and 18th in San Francisco October 17 18th the DC musters 2/3 sold-out right now
two-thirds sold-out
And it's gonna sell out soon the SF muster is in October and it's already a third sold-out so both of them are absolutely
Going to sell out we can't expand the spaces anymore. We've packed as as many chairs
Is there in there as we can and desk so you we can't fit any more people so if you want to come get registered?
Now at extreme ownership. Calm the entire Ashland front team will be there all of us
including echo Charles and
By the way, there's no green room. We won't be backstage
Getting our
Getting our scalps massaged
No, we will be out front kicking it with you interacting answering questions talking eating working out hanging out just
Basically getting after it with you
so
Come and get it at the monster at the monster get registered as quick as you can and until we do the muster if you
Have questions or comments or answers or you just want to cruise?
With us kind of hard then you can find us on the interwebs on Twitter on Instagram and on
defy easy
HECO is
that echo Charles
And I am at Jocko willing and thanks to you all for listening to the podcast especially those of you in uniform
Who took an oath to protect this country, and you stand by that oath?
Literally around the world on the front lines and to the police and law enforcement and firefighters and paramedics
And all the first responders that are always on
Call to help us when the chips are down and then are ready to make that sacrifice
Like so many did on September 11th. Thank you for what you do and
Let's remember and give thanks to the people every day like Jeremy Glick who stood up
Along with the other members of flight 93 they stood up and fought when the time called for it
Then let us all be prepared
To do the same to stand up and fight if we need to to be prepared to face
Evil by staying on the path by knowing what your principles are and sticking to them
Be vigilant
Pay attention pay attention
To the little things the little decisions the decisions that pull you off the path and onto that
slippery slope
With bad habits that will let you down at the moment of truth
Watch out
for those little decisions instead stay on the path the path of discipline the path that leads to
security and strength and of course to freedom
And that's the path of getting after it
So until next time this is echo and Jocko